welcome everybody to the penultimate
match of the opening round of the speed
chess championship i'm grand master
robert hess alongside me my good friend
grandmaster marie sashi maurice are you
ready for this
jan christoph duda versus fabi showdown
robert you know i was born ready what's
up what's up we're gonna do this it's
gonna be fun
fabi versus duda this one should be
interesting
i'm hearing some hate for fobby but
we'll see how
the big dog gets it done you know he's
number two in the world for a reason
he certainly is number two in the world
classical chess this is a blitz format
which
hasn't always been his specialty and as
we remind everybody what the format is
today
same as usual it is a single elimination
knockout bracket
there will be 90 minutes an hour and a
half of five minute plus one second
increment time control chest
followed by an hour of three plus one
and then finally we get our 30 minutes
of bullet
one minute plus one second increment the
action will really heat up and if a
match is tied we will get four
additional bullet matches
that should favor young christophe duda
we'll talk about that in a moment
but before we do maurice the prize fund
thirty-two thousand dollars
are dished out in the opening yeah
exactly cash money right two thousand
bucks to the winner
plus two thousand split by win
percentage and what do you think about
that because it does motivate people to
play every single game
you know we did the same thing with
clutch chess to add a little
spice to it it is important i think the
players sometimes when they get
their heads bashed in it's hard to keep
playing you don't want to play any more
games
please please could i resign could i be
out of here but hey if there's a little
bit of extra cash on the line
let's keep playing why not motivate them
a little bit more
and if uh they need any more motivation
wesley so
awaits the winner of this match in the
quarterfinals
of the speedchest championship and marie
says you look across the bracket
i can't really imagine there are
surprises this early
but what do you make of the participants
in the
uh quarterfinals and who do you think is
going to
win tomorrow's matchup before we get to
today's between anish giri and vladislav
artemyev
well these are big names in chess
there's no surprises here they're people
who are just
animals sharks i mean you look at levon
aronian
what he did to nepo i mean these are
just fantastic players these are the
world's
elite so i think this one is awesome
when we get the chance to get down to
the next level in the next level
and the next level i gotta say artemiev
is really impressive man he's scary
he's scary of course anybody could win
the match but
i'd say watch out for him okay i think
that's a fair call magnus carlson
really hinted as much saying that he
wants to play the stronger player was
trolling a niche but
it's true artemia is an absolute beast
and well those players will be playing
tomorrow but everybody who's watching
can get involved today
because there is money at stake for our
viewers
if you guess the move on chess.com you
have a chance at some prize money
there are grandmasters and other title
players taking part in it but that
doesn't mean that they're going to win
and the game that is chosen is not yet
selected so you just have to participate
as much as possible
and get a chance to win some cash money
and you know bragging rights some glory
just guess the move
exactly i wanted you to say that i
didn't want to say it so i'm glad you
took the lead there and maurice
now it's time for jan christoph duda
versus fabiano caruana
you see that their blitz ratings are
such that duda
a bit higher rated his performance in
speed chess championships past
is clearly better and he is predicted to
win according to our smarter chess
predictions brought to us by chess goals
i have a problem
with this graphic but i always have
problems with smart chess predictions so
maurice what do you think about this
i mean 77
now the number two player in the world
is going to get mauled i mean
that just seems a bit outrageous
i get it it looks as though he's skewing
high in the bullet portion
where you really have to be somebody who
plays a lot of bullet
over and over and over again to really
get it but geez to just
see bobby getting this kind of
disrespect
i mean uh maybe 60 40 but 77 23
that's just a blowout no love at all i i
think it's
preposterous i'm pretty upset about it
but i understand it at the same time
fabi has not proven historically to be
the best
online speeches player that said during
this unfortunate pandemic
he clearly has improved his game all the
various events that he has
taken part in has shown that he is a
promising
blitz player these days and i think that
it will be much closer than that
prediction indicates
seven to three in bullet what is a one
second increment
not buying it not today but maurice
i'll add as well there's no category
that he's been giving any edge
zero okay like no love for him in any
category that's
i fabi c has known this number
beforehand if he knows it he's got to be
really ticked off and ready to take this
personally
try to take dude down and prove the
world wrong well
we're going to have him try to prove
that in just a moment because
the game should start any second now and
yeah maurice i can't get over that i
mean
no advantages whatsoever but let's see
if he can create an advantage over the
board
we do have lived off and oh the french
don't do this to me maurice oh i can't
handle it
hating on the french but bobby's no
doubt going to try to surprise
his opponent with some different ideas
both of them looking sharp
fresh by the way you see that they're
all cleaned up
fabi's hair is significantly shorter
than in the
promo pic so we'll see if that's because
he's ready
to play some fresh moves on the board
this french
i'm not a fan i don't like having my
bishop stuck on c8
and crammed and trying to break out of a
structure when white has all the space
yeah but fabi has been known to play it
before and it's a very complex position
yeah it's funny because i've seen fabi
crush opponents on the white side of
french's in
u.s championships past in particular and
this bishop on c8 it's
typically a horrendous piece but why is
duda spending some time here like why
did he take so long before playing
bishop e2 this
is still mainline theory i guess he was
choosing do i want to castle queenside
or kingside
well he knows fabi did not just drop
this on the board
out of the sky i mean fabian has
prepared this specifically for this
match
he's thought about it carefully he's one
of the best prepared players on the
planet
if anything you'll say fabi's main
strength is his preparation is opening
ideas that he's going to come with
to beat you down so clearly duda wants
to get into something a little bit
different maybe not the most popular
position
and maybe not the sharpest lines that
fabi has analyzed in depth to the finish
yeah and there are possibilities to
exchange a lot of pieces on the d4
square which i'm highlighting here
and perhaps that's what fabi wants in
game one is
an end game something that isn't too
sharp because in a lot of positions
white can try to blast through f5 but
not happening when d4
and then e5 will collapse so he is
preventing the more aggressive plans
and now duda spending even more time are
we sure that dude is going to be the
favorite in this match
based on the early clock usage as you
said maurice preparation favoring
fabiano
yes indeed and that's a lot of time to
be burning right now is it move
12 or something i mean this is this is
crazy that this
much thought went into this early
opposition
and finally he did capture on the c5
square
we'll see more trades occur without a
doubt the dark square bishops will be
coming off the board
without any question and there we go and
you got to say fabi for the clock as far
as this position is concerned
not only that i don't see the domination
by white here
it seems as though d4 will happen very
soon for black
can he do it even now robert can can he
drop in a d4 move
definitely right because if d4 and if
you take with the knight there's gonna
be a
quick rook b8 but he plays bishop b7
first so
yeah that that that's a little
surprising to me i would have loved
to put a pawn on d4 and also chase the
the knight that's on c3 to a weird
circuit
yeah let's take a look at that we'll
bring up the analysis board here just to
go back and move here because d4
maurice ideas kick this knight and if
the knight captures on d4
here comes a rook d8 and that's a
devastating thing
that's absolutely deadly and and where
would the knight on
c3 go before this this is my key point
he'd have to play knight d1 and send it
over to f2
etc but what what do we hate on this one
our bishop on b7 with a rook on the
d-line
and it's party all day i'm surprised
that he didn't go for this line
he played bishop b7 instead and bishop
d3 came immediately and now the question
after d4 is can he just play knight e4
and say
hey thanks no problem you let my knight
get to a decent square
so a little bit problematic in my mind
by fabi and now he spent
some time before finally playing rook
ada and
looking again to maybe playing d4 in the
future
seems like he missed the opportunity
just a second before i'm with you
maurice because
uh now if he puts his pawn on d4 he's
probably worried about the eventual end
game
has that pawn gone too far and becoming
a weakness
rather than a potential strength and
queen f2 played pinning this knight on
c5 and
covering the d4 square a little more i
also was threatening
also threatening the blast bishop 87
check and finish you off
so good point sticks to deal with that
uh that's a very good point that's why
h6 was played because of that
typical sacrifice he makes them look
like rook d7 in comes the sacrifice
queen h4 knight g5 queen h7 all
happening very quickly so instead we got
h6
stopping all of that at once no knight
g5s no bishop sacrifices
uh but i am surprised maurice and we
have been talking about it but the fact
that he didn't play d4
what do you think that says about fabi
more generally are we reading too much
into it if we start speculating
let's just say he missed it let's just
say he missed that chance for now
and that's all let's they're both
warming up duda not playing with his
normal alacrity he's down at
211 right now fabi also
maybe not finding all the nuances
instantly or that opportunity when it
knocks
but it could be a big deal guys a big
deal
because now duda has all this space
robert
d4 doesn't make any sense at all now
zero sense
forget it fabi has got to look for play
from somewhere
the threat is rook to e1 rook ae1
followed by f5 and blast away where is
black's counterplay
i'm not seeing it right that's the big
problem is once that knight got kicked
back to d7 and then white's queen
swung into the action here it feels like
white has a very
free hand and normally make moves like
f6 the typical move to play in the
french to chisel at white structure but
that's two weakening look at these light
squares that are
going to be penetrated by white's pieces
so
i mean i i'm just not seeing an easy
move for fabi
and now the clock situation look at that
you made the point you made a great
point the clock situation
is indicative of the fact that black has
gotten a worse
version of the french than you want to
have you want some play you want to move
and now he has played f6 because what
else is there to do robert
the black is stuck for a plan black had
no normal peace moves
pawn breaks a5 who cares you're about to
get killed on king side
he had to do something to compete with
the attack on this side of the board
yeah so he plays f6 and at the very
least what can capture on f6 bring that
rook a to e1 that you suggested
and e6 becoming a quick target but oh
the
evaluation bar did not like the capture
on f6
and okay it's swinging back and forth a
bit uncertain
about the longer term prospects of this
but i see that pawn e6 maurice
i'm not liking that well there's gonna
have to be some kind of tricky tactic
somewhere i think that a
an e5 move by black's gonna have to come
with some weirdness
the problem i have for black's position
right now is that knight on c6 and that
bishop on b7 these pieces have to
breathe somehow how are they going to
get in the game
can he play maybe knight e7 to f5 robert
and
hope for rain in a line like that i pray
that
you don't get killed maybe that's the
best thing to do because those pieces
now are just con
highly congested on that side of the
board and unless you can find a break
like e5
i mean you can't play it you can't play
you've got to go for a
this knight move somewhere either d4 or
e7 and pray you're not dying on the spot
yeah knight d4 is an interesting one
trading off some of the pieces and
avoiding maybe a more menacing attack
but this what i'm having trouble with
maurice here is that even if you
fend off the attack there's still some
positional weaknesses in particulars
upon e6 but
i like your idea your more general
approach of saying i need to open up the
bishop my knight c6 isn't doing so much
so let me make a move like knight d4 to
trade off what could be
a very aggressive piece piece because
knight g5
in many variations is a threat going
after e6 and saying haha you can't take
me
because my bishop and queen will line up
on the h7 square so
i do like your knight d4 move just to
get rid of some of the attackers
but robert is it a stone cold blunder
because fabi's sitting here
30 40 maybe it's been a minute already
that he's sitting on this position
ticking down to 106. remember that
gigantic edge he had on the clock
and finally he's doubled rooks but you
know you you got to double rooks quickly
and f5 on the board knight to e8
now backing up hoping against hope as
his pieces have become
really weird even more weird we had a
nice possibility of being on d4 now it's
on d8
and with the f5 break white's pieces are
breathing
i i'm not feeling this position at all
but maybe he's still okay maybe his
bishop
on b7 is holding things together on the
square
d5 yeah that's important and i like how
duda is
transferring his advantage because the
pawn e6 was backward and weak at target
but he's saying let me play f5 and take
and then give black an isolated pawn
but at the same time as you're
highlighting it frees up black's pieces
this knight come in e6 you pre-move that
now this knight from c6 to e6 that's
closer to the king side
it'll can go to f4 eventually don't drop
your knight on d7 if that knight moves
out the way and queen d6
it feels like fabi has completely
regrouped at the stage and the clock
it's been telling the story of the game
race
33 seconds of counting down for duda
this is what fabi was counting on these
complex french's
and remember we said we wanted to see
the move e5
happen well it was ordered in order to
remove that weakness
break open the game and give black some
room but f5 has done
for black what e5 himself would have
done
in a position like that and the game is
open black's pieces are much more
coordinated right now
and this move knight to d1 robert that's
not saying anything
bobby just needs to start pressing
forward and do it quickly knight f4
boss move this is starting to look
really good for black
i'm looking at your d4 move now open
that bishop attack tonight on e3 he's go
he's probably going for it because
knight can't get to f5 so d4 simply
kicks the knight back i guess it hangs
the pawn but
there's so many tactics available that
rook out for first that's that's a great
start
great start and this is all fabi now 12
seconds left for duda and he has no
pieces to
to talk about when his queen moves d4 is
going to happen he's just
like queen g3 d4 on the board he's got
six seconds and he's got to figure out
what to do he's got to make a move
bishop takes f3 works because if rook
takes f3 then you could sacrifice your
queen for a back rank checkmate but he's
going for the same idea at knight e5
piling up the pressure here is there
rook g4 can that
do the trick yes sure rook g4 looks
great right now is
and he can take with the queen and g2 is
hanging and now he's just sacrificing
his queen of admitting this position
is busted now favi just has to get the
job done with 20 seconds left two
seconds
for due to threats are going to start
hovering the knights are hoping that
somehow they can hold it together but
nope quincy won give me a piece
bobby gets it done in the first game
with black from an inferior position
he does and we'll pull up the analysis
board really quickly because i want to
show something that fabi did
which was excellent uh at this moment
when the rook captured on f8
on move 30 a lot of people say i need to
keep my knight protect it's all under
attack but you're losing that piece
anyway and much more important
is keeping your king safe and then so
you could take on g2 so taking with the
king that reflex
was really smart uh started not taking
the king too too the queen
was really smart by fabi because getting
the king there allows a check and maybe
some defense
queen takes as you're losing g2 by force
and that's that
so indeed that was certainly a fantastic
performance
there by fabi and he
he needed that win to start to quiet the
haters
quality haters who say he's going to get
blasted if he keeps playing like this
all right let's be real though that was
an uneven game on both
their parts duder needs to get into this
match
like start to start to play with some
speed first of all
don't get behind the way he did on the
clock initially i mean that was
crazy like right out of the opening
remember he was how long he spent
on deciding to play bishop e2 as you
mentioned you cannot afford to do that
in these matches
certainly not because he could have used
that time towards the end of the game
and
oh i see what just happened here and the
evaluation bar is always telling
it was at minus something minus almost
one
and then it went down to slightly better
for white which means queen e6 probably
was the trick hitting both pawns at the
same time and actually
there's no real way for white to protect
both because queen d3
runs into knight e5 so you protect e4
and c4 at once but i immediately kick
you out the way
so queen e6 maurice that looks like a
missed opportunity
did duda think that maybe there was a
trick a trap
a preparation by fabi waiting in the
position
we know fabi is famous for dropping
little nuances there
but you looks good to me we'll see
whether or not they go back in this line
if fabi repeats it means that he's
confident that he did have a trick
if not then he would say wait a minute i
think i messed up my
preparation there the guy could have
played queen e6 so we'll see these
matches
we get to see a lot of games you're
going to see the theory repeated
again and again they can't play new
positions every single time
certainly not and i do think that queen
e6 is a move you
almost never play right so trying to say
oh queen e6 here makes sense
you're much more likely to just play
your typical stuff because the queen on
d8 is a good square
it defends e7 in the event excuse me in
the event of any kind of knight d5 and
it
also can allow the queen to go over
towards the queen side and be useful
there so it's a good square to have the
queen on more generally in these
moroxy bind structures but the bind is
over marie's the
trade on b5 yes indeed and the point you
make is such a good point the knight on
d5
also often threatens to go to b6 forking
anything that's sitting if there's a
rook on a when the queen's on d7
everybody's getting forked by knight b6
but the queen on d8 and now the rook on
b8 there is no knight b6
that's just history and nothing for
black to worry about
and as you said the bind is gone usually
when the bind leaves
especially the king still on g1 and the
pawn on h3 robert
who who's worried if you got the black
pieces certainly not me
i'm with you i could tell by the way
you're saying it and black's mission
looks good and i'm
here with you and actually that was a
great point by you about the b6 square
because knight d5 if that queen were on
d7
there would be immediate problems but
here you could probably play the move e6
and say
what now the b6 square is covered no
issues in black's position trading off
pieces
that's why um probably drop his knight
back rook a8
and okay that pawn a2 not exactly happy
but how to make progress here because it
seems like white's going to play rook c2
rook c1 and take over this open c file
so i kind of like white's position
from a concrete point of view but from a
like
the thought process of my rook on it's
powerful that
is the only thing i'm going for the
bishop on g7 the rook on the 8th but
that's
not actually accomplishing all that much
right now i'm going to say that the move
rook 8
actually is not an impressive move to me
because
the knight on c6 is now tethered to the
b4 pawn
and so by moving your rook away and
letting white consolidate with the move
b3
and and also guarding the c4 square
white was going to do that anyway
right why was this going to do that
anyway so now you've created a situation
where your knight on c6
has to sit there pretty much forever
unless you defend that sucker
again with somebody else the rook was
taking care of the job
of guarding that pawn you could have
played rookie any time you wanted to
and he would have played b3 anyway so
i'm a little bit i feel like
it was a slightly inaccurate move and
maybe this knight should have found e5
and play in that fashion even here you
might want to play
something like a 95 at some point
looking at the d3 square in the long run
but you can't move it like you just
can't move it so now white is just piled
up on the c line
and black is checking out like what
should he do how do you
how do you clarify the situation on the
board that's a
an excellent point that rookie had that
one move threat the palm was under
attack but white's very
obvious reply helped the case for
fabiano so
here black does feel a bit stuck so
let's try to answer that question how do
you defend b4 in a meaningful way
is white ready to take on c5 because
that is a hanging pawn
so if white wants to you can take on c5
give up your bishop
and say a pawn is a pawn and right 95
sorry robert knight d5 was a threat as
well
95 going after the pawn on on beef
uh four and also the knight b6 idea with
the rook on ba on
ba was guarding it the rook on a8 now
your queen can't leave
so that that idea came back and he said
wait i can't move my queen i can't do
anything
i need to play the move e6 to stop the
knight from going to d5 and now that has
also weakened the d6 pawn
it certainly hasn't i probably would not
capture on c5 it's a way to steal upon
the initial position but that makes a2
loose and it's an unopposed dark score
bishop a move i would consider though is
knight d3 but instead he focuses his
energy
on the d6 pawn right away is he just
going to scoop that off
if you give him the opportunity he
certainly would like to and i guess
black should make him like bishop e5
to defend while putting the bishop on a
more aggressive square
robert the challenge here for black is
to find the concrete plan that maneuvers
the pieces in just the right way
that's going to be the challenge white i
think should move the king off of g1 and
there's a the bishop move and this is
exposing the pieces
you know that that bishop is a problem
the knight on c5 is a problem the pawn
on
d6 is the only thing that's helping it
this is a
just a second moment where blackwell
looks like he has to
has to play knight takes d3 i'm not
really sure why he's taking so long do
you see another move
it looks like looks like it's forced
maybe he was trying to make the
follow-up as quickly as possible so he
was spending his time on the second move
rather than on knight 63 which
i agree that was the very obvious move
and the opportunity that i mentioned
to get the knight off of c6 finally when
the b4 pawn is not hanging
this is a very critical moment for black
right now now that bishop on e5 looks
like it should be getting kicked with f4
i'm not sure why why you would hesitate
there
either it's not like your e4 pawn is
going to come under fire so f4 seems
natural robert
why would bobby wait here i guess
there's the decision to be made about
the stare down the c
file because i could take on c2 which
relieves the pressure on d6 and also
removes a very important defender
in the long run of the pawn a2 but if
you take on c8 maybe this knight can
even capture it to
get passive for the time being but again
a2
is a problem that white needs to keep an
eye on himself so
f4 definitely that's the idea i'm
looking to play as well
but making it all work is a little bit
more difficult it seems
all right well the knight did take on ca
the d6 pawn is
guarded forever now it is not going to
be a target
you've got to hope your maybe your light
square pressure will be a factor
i i got to tell you i'm not i wasn't
really a fan of this move rook takes
and again you see black now playing the
move queen a5 hitting the a pawn
guarding the b4 point no kind of
pressure on this pawn
on d6 oh don't take on a2 fabi with a
trick
don't touch that that you you would
certainly lose instantly to rook c8
as the rook would be overworked and you
know it's an idea here maurices
a4 because with this knight needing the
rook's defense a move like a4 could be
possible
trying to take advantage of an
overworked rook so
that's a big decision now for jkd is
hey a4 would close the a file and then
make b4 even look
worse so he needs to figure out a way to
stop that move from being played
he could play king g7 but bishop h6
chases him
back and that's so he cannot do that for
that reason but now he's played
this move a4 take advantage of the pin
pawn
but also this is a pawn sack well not
quite
this is a very touch and go movie just
played f4 followed by queen takes d6 is
playable but you hang b2
is i mean a2 i mean is that
hmm no a4 may be the way the positional
way
to handle it as you said guard b5 the
knight has no
path into the game and you keep all your
threats i like it
and there it is and the point is after b
takes a three on poisson that drops the
queen because the rook no longer defends
it
so we will not be seeing that on poisson
move that's for sure
and that was still a move even with the
knight back on state we'll go back a
quick second here let's say played a
move like
h5 a4 as possible because it takes on
passant as rook takes c8 with check
the rook is overworked protecting the
knight and protecting the queen so that
tactic was available
whether the knight went to a7 or
remained on c8 but after a4 here
jkd deep in the think tank plays queen
a6 but maurice
it's very clear that white's position
has improved and importantly his pawn on
f3 still
makes his center feel strong here so he
didn't even have to commit himself to
anything
fabio not yet i think he will eventually
because black's bishop is just too
strong
holding that square now the rook back to
b8 a rook that should never have
left the b8 square in my opinion and
only 16 seconds left
in this position 35 for fabi fabi just
needs to find a couple of improving
moves
at the moment keep the pressure on his
opponent is there a threat
for black none that we can spot maybe
the d5 move
is something he was hoping for but he
needs to make moves quickly now
as does fabi how does he improve get
some pressure
f4 finally in the position and knight
back to f3
here we go you can just take that if you
want it because you can't take with the
queen and the queen is stuck defending
this 987
you've given black and iceland f5
crashing through
this is it this is beasty play
by fabi now completely outplaying his
opponent world class chess
as those pawns are split all the pawns
in black's position
are split every which way there's got to
be multiple ways to win this position
but he's got to do it quickly he himself
only has 12 seconds left and here comes
queen 87 with bishop c5 to follow in
fact bishop c5 said bishop f2 was
probably stronger but here it comes
bishop's got pinning the knight
rook f1 maybe here it comes oh yeah
everything is a threat right now and i
think
probably just dropping your queen back
yum yum
smacking on something and now he's found
the killer blow bishop d6 followed by
rook f7 hello
that's it no no mas no mas
fabiano caruana rolling right now oh he
is and that was a
nice way to finish that game we'll bring
up the board one more time
very quickly to show how he broke
through and
it's in some ways jkd asked for it by
playing d5 himself
towards the end there because by playing
d5 he got rid of his
defenders on the f5 score but that's
happening regardless so take takes an f5
crashing through very quickly blacks
pieces over over on the queen side not
helping
this poor king on g8 and the rest was
very simple for
fabi crashing through here so pure class
robert that was pure
class chess right there held attention
and then broke through when his opponent
made the critical error
fantastic play so far by fabi and it
feels like he's warming up as well
that's the other thing it feels like he
hasn't played his best chess yet is that
scary to say
because he seems like he's getting in a
groove
dude i better find something quickly or
else this match
i'm not going to say it could be over
there is a lot of bullet to play so a
lot of games but man bobby on a roll
right now
and look at this game maurice he learned
from his first game i guess he played b4
first instead of putting the queen on b6
and after b4 knight d1
a5 so he simply expanded over here on
the queen side
and that's what white you know white
goes for the king side black goes for
the queen side it's kind of the point
c4 am i am i seeing this is this
real you can play c4 that's
uh okay that's not what they teach you
in the classical manuals robert you're
supposed to be going for f5
not attacking on the same side as your
opponent
is to play such a move just seems like
it should not work out
is there a d5 sighting right now is that
some kind of madness i don't think that
could
possibly work and if it doesn't then
black simply captures on d4
and then puts his bishop on b7 and says
thanks for freeing my
one bad piece that i've been crying
about
what is this i don't know and he's
spending so much time here that
i'm having a hard time figuring it out
because knight b6 heading to d5 as well
it's not just the diagonal you've given
black to d5 square there's a pawn there
both blocking the bishop and taking away
from black's pieces so
i don't like this at all for young
christophe duda the
engine the evaluation bar clearly
slightly favoring
fabiano and the lead on the scoreboard
two nothing smarter chess where you at
where you at with that 78 or whatever it
was
there's a long way to go robert let's
not speak too early still
but i agree 2-zip to start and
two classy games as well not like all
the guy blundered
and we see their quiet move by by fabi
maybe your knight v6 was a bit more
a little had a little bit more oomph to
it but bishop b7 you can't hate him for
trying to get his bishop on a sweet
diagonal look at that bishop just
slicing down
and this may be the time for white to
play d5 you're pointing out the bishop
is looking
nice and strong there so playing d5 can
close the diagonal
and force black to capture there because
d5 e takes d5 bishop takes d5
maybe my bishop can sit on e4 where it's
challenging yours on this
nicely open long diagonal of course
black can just play knight b6 and into
c4 so
not that great for white i totally agree
this this is a challenge but knight b6
as you said knight b6 is coming on the
next move and
no problem there and it looks like we
have seen
the position robert you called it
now we do have a an imbalance
and it is dynamic in fact white has
freed his pawns maybe your knight v6
earlier like i said
instead of the bishop b7 move would have
been far more pressing
more to the point but now white is
thinking dreaming one day
please let me play f5 f6 let me keep
queens on as well could i keep the
queens on fabi said no no no
that's that's what happens when you
start threatening me
we trade queens off make sure that
cannot happen but the problem for black
at the moment
is that bishop on b7 although it's solid
although it's good
it's face is being faced off by this
bishop on e4 so white got to sneak that
in
can black make some moves get a knight
maybe on c4 at some point
how does we chase away this bishop over
the e4 square
that said robert you can't like white
pieces they look silly other than the
bishop on e4
everybody else looks silly but there are
prospects right because it's pawn c5 we
have to take into account that
there's an extra pawn for both sides and
different sides of the board right from
the e to the h file
white has an extra pawn from the a
through c files black has an extra pawn
that typically favors the extra pawn on
the queen side in the end game
because look at how far these king on h1
is from black's extra pawn whereas
white's extra pawn e5
this king is super close just to think
about that as we
may see some trades in the future and as
you were pointing out maurice black's
pieces are definitely better plays the
bishop on d2 doing a whole lot of
nothing
the knight on e3 would love to jump into
f5 but the question is
then what right you get to f5 great you
attack my bishop i can move my bishop
away
you're not really making the progress
you so desire and on the other side of
things
black's pieces are ready to just jump
into the action
robert i want to play knight f5 and then
when you move your bishop like queen g4
where's my queen i mean that's what you
do when you have the space on the king
side to attack with
the reality is with this pawn formation
you're going to need and before i could
even finish the thought
you're going to need to play f5 and e6
creating your own pass pawn he just
played the move g6 saying you want to
try that
go right ahead there's no knight to f5
nothing there's not there's no nothing
over there if i'm gonna use a double
negative
and piss off my english teacher from
grade school there is
not there's no na on that side of the
board for white white has to be thinking
how do i settle down black because black
is looking at moves like c4
like you said starting to get some some
angles and might even play a bishop d3
black has all kinds of options in fact
it's probably the problem for black is
how many moves does black have is there
a knight a4
sighting in man that's a little bit too
too much maybe now i'm liking c4
eventually with
with the possibility of of more pressure
in the position and
white just looking for things to do
can't find any moves i'm talking all
this time robert
the guy is losing the same amount of
time on the claw yes
you're absolutely right maurice and if
you you're kind of highlighting this but
the squares
black has d5 under control which is what
white's pieces want to go to
f5 we're looking at that square nope not
for you whereas d3 you can put that
bishop and double the rooks bring the
next one over
it just feels like black dominates the
control of this board here
and knight g4 are you really trying to
go knight f6 i can just take you there
right and
thank you very much you moved your night
away thank you here's an attack on both
bishop and pawn on b2 this just is
getting
from bad to worse for what that last
move was not it
knight g4 was just a drop you need to
make a move my time is ticking i've got
to do something would have been better
to play move h3
or king g1 but knight g4 there's no
threat you're you
left control of the c4 square and
allowed a knight to park itself on c4
now it's up to fabi fabi wants to find
something nasty right now
is it a four i wanted to play a4 with
the idea of
playing b3 but the opponent he does have
the move b3 himself so
that's a little bit tricky what's the
way to to
amp up the pressure in this position i
don't quite see it is it h5
chasing him back no knight d4 finally
just putting the knight on a central
square and chasing him backwards and as
you said robert he could double on the d
line
yeah he's just saying i don't mind the
trade because your bishop still can't go
anywhere and let me go rook d1 next if
you're not careful and rook takes e4 was
an immediate threat
it was an immediate threat indeed knight
back guarding everything
there's no bishop h4 trickery i want to
force
g3 but i want to do it if i could play
bishop somewhere else
afterwards just just to lighten up that
diagonal for some tactics with rookie
for later
but no if only if my bishop could go to
a great square on the next move but i
want to waste
this tempo in this way because i don't
want white to have a free move
after this so the real threat it looks
like is going to be
b3 robert where is the knight going to
go maybe she'll play a4
now and if b3 take and then play knight
back to a5
i'm with you there it softens up the
square you're gonna just go
go right after this pawn in many of
these positions you can even sacrifice
an exchange as long as you get this pawn
so i i see that the evil bar doesn't
look oh my gosh knight d2
knight d2 in we go uh
i'll i'll take back my a4 and say
he should play knight d2 i mean knights
normally don't land
on the seventh rank your opponent's
second rank like this
just to park themselves there but oh man
this guy has got valet parking on the d2
square right now
look at that beast hitting the bishop
and
prepping everything else i mean also by
the way opening the diagonal for his
bishop on a6
the square control is marvelous i mean
jeez this is terrible where's the bishop
going to go
and you know maurice we were focusing on
a4 b3 you can even play c4 b3 if uh
white allowed it
to oh this is he had to take he had to
take her but his bishop on c6 would have
been atrocious
and now there's going to be tactics
there's going to be tactics in a
position like this one
but in the meantime c4 more board
control man fabi is playing like a
beast i mean jeez leave the guy alone
bobby
look at these moosies dropping on him
and now the question is what's the
killer blow
the the knight in f2 looks tenderoni b3
looks
i mean that just looks like it right
doesn't that look like it
looks winning you just play b3 kick the
rook and then if the rook trades the
second one comes out hitting
okay he just wants it all look at the
guy a4
domination make a move and your opponent
doesn't even know what you're
threatening necessarily
can he play 94 now i mean
he's got to make a move he's only got 20
seconds left he's being completely owned
and 94 was totally forced and here comes
those
pawns there's gonna be a passer real
soon look at this
in comes a3 next and the bishops with
the pass pawn that's just game over and
what a
gorgeous chess dominant chess amazing
play
wow this is this is oh no this has got
to be over
by the way bishop bishop b7 forces you
to go
all the way back home because of a
tactic and a3 is going to happen
anyway he's calculating a3 but he only
has
20 seconds left so he's got to find the
right path here and he did finally play
it forcing that piece back
and what's what would be wrong with a3
he's decided
yeah you know what i'm going to snack
i'm going to go
why don't you play it right right right
through just winning a3 was it is
winning right now
same thing right right already b2 and
the guy's going to be tied down
for the rest of all time and also as you
said rook c4
is coming with rook c1 oh it's all yeah
it's complete bishop c5 for good measure
now
if you want it rook c4 of course is just
rooksy one next
rook c bishop c5 at the end bishop d3
holds b1
oh my gosh you wanted to see it i know
you
i could see it was hurting you that he
didn't actually play it
you wanted to see the move on the board
show it robert show it to the fans so
they can appreciate
that finish bishop d3 trying to hold but
no
bishop c5 and that's it rook f1 met by
a simple trade on f1 and then queening
3-0 to start
this is just a straight
i told you he hadn't played his best
chess yet did i say he hadn't played his
best chess yet he was up 2-0 robert and
he hadn't played his best chess yet
that right there was a master class
that was a master class what play by
fabi
from start to finish just in flow 3-zip
wow and that's the problem maurice is
when you're playing somebody as strong
as fabiano and you give him that
confidence
we know he has not always been the
finest speed chess player in the world
but right now this guy looks unbeatable
he has made
almost no mistakes with the exception
that first game when he didn't play d4
is black we both were
critical of it and deservedly so but
since then it's been
all fabiano the entire way and
and do the shoes now all right we got a
guy's a clock world-class player he's 3
000 rated
in in blitz for a reason
he's got to stop the bleeding we've seen
this happen time and time again
he's got to stop the bleeding right now
get first of all he's got to speed up
look at it look at him
the way he's wiping his his face holding
his brow he's like
yo i'm getting hit i'm getting hit
you need to stop the bleeding quickly
get a solid position
trade off some pieces get a draw and
maybe make another one
and then start playing chess because
right now
if he keeps playing and if he gets
highly aggressive trying to get those
points back right away robert
he could be down four or five nothing
and the match may be just over
well not if uh smarter chess's bullet
predictions come true with a 7-3
advantage
for duda and i love just arguing with
smarter chess predictions like my
favorite thing to do
and as you see on the screen 77 favorite
winning five four in the five minute i
don't think so
five four in this time control three
nothing fabiano right now predictions
already off
that prediction we can already throw out
the window he would have to win
the next three for us to start saying
it's possible
it's you know it's theoretically but
like even in this position
i'm sorry but already i like white you
tell me you don't like the bishop pair
because the bishop on f6 isn't the most
dominant bishop you've ever seen
[Music]
well well you know i'm just going to say
i like white how does white now build on
this
position positional advantage that he
has and
again he's got to get back in business
on the clock
does duda he cannot keep being worse on
the clock
just you just can't and fabi now just
playing straightforward
chess taking and saying i got double
pawns let me go after your
f6 pawn now this kind of play
it it's typical it's classical play
against
weaknesses but black has shown that in
these kind of freshly called structures
it's not necessarily that easy to crack
black's kingside
so i'm not sure 96 was the best way to
play in this position
as i don't see white's natural follow-up
and the threat of
d5 for black will be in the position as
well as night before and a rook on the
sea line
so the queen leaving in this way after
knight of six queen eight six robert i
gotta say i felt like
that exchange and maneuver may not have
been the best for black foreign
to demonstrate that i'm with you maurice
because the bind was more important to
me than the double pawns yeah you give
black these double pawns makes the king
look less safe but you have to prove it
whereas the knight is doing a great job
just
saying you're restricted completely this
knight before i do the mercy mention
not available and i can take you on f6
when i want to
you do not want to take on d5 that would
be a choice that gives white
complete control because of this
backward pawn and this bad bishop on f6
so i'm totally there with you maurice
that taking on f6
it felt like it relieves the pressure
that black was under unless fob you can
prove it directly with f4
and i guess he's trying to play f5 g4 g5
and crash through
so you believe if you're white that you
are not going to face
any counter play by the way i don't
understand why
king h8 i would have been aiming
i mean he's decided to cover up on on
the side of the board where white is
attacking what is duda
doing you just he just sees the
defensive
we were talking about the counter play
on the other side you should have been
thinking rook c8 knight b4
if you're going to take on the on the b3
square
you know let okay you're going to do it
anyway so let it play is that f5 move
but right now this last maneuver i am
not feeling
i think he thought he would be getting
play mate
shouldn't fabi have been sacrificing in
that last i don't know
i was thinking about being able to play
for bishop attack rook and then pawn
but now that i'm thinking about there's
a queen f8 defense that no queen of face
not a defense there's a queen of six
so i don't know it felt like there was a
sacrifice in there robert
now black seems to have pushed white
back at least a little bit
here although i do feel like playing c3
and sacking my b-pawn
i'm with you c3 looks really strong to
kick this knight and give up the b-pun
i'm gonna go back to that moment just
because we uh have the now support
option you wanted to kick this rook
right with some kind of like bishop h3
and then just play g4 g5
and look i actually wanted to play
bishop to e2 but i'd have to
i'd have to work again with the next
tempo
so this this is probably i mean this is
what i wanted to do
i didn't want to just put my bishop on
h3 but now that i now
that's clear let's play bishop h3 and
play g4 and ask what was
black's next move against this very
direct demonstration f6 is hanging maybe
he could wait until g5 and then
take and play for i don't know it just
felt like bl
white would naturally do this to get
compensation but
it is a sacrifice it is your sent upon
it's not it's fabi's center pawn not
mine
so he's like nah i'm not sacking it i'll
get it later i'll get an idea like this
in time although i'm i'm with you i mean
this attack looks very strong but
fabi's saying hey those are not your
pieces guys you can sacrifice them but i
have to pay
the price if i do it's right but it's
your game you sack him
in the meantime he doesn't have to rush
i mean he can just wait
here you see him just saying let me be
patient let me develop the strength of
my position and sooner or later i'm
going to play the move c3
trust me i'm going to kick that one out
then i'm going to play bishop to e2
and i'm gonna kick that workout then i'm
gonna play g4 and the queen on c7
that that's not an attacking queen that
queen's gonna have to go back to e7 when
queen h6 lands on the board
queen eight don't think your queen is
roaming your queen's not
going anywhere this is you know this is
not sprint and verizon you're not
roaming
there's there's going to be charges to
the roaming because the queen 86
the pawn on f6 will be untenable and so
the queen has to stick around
because of that tactic that's an
exceptional point maurice the queen
coming back to h6 will force queen e7 so
we know
that we can get a position with the
queen on h6 and the queen of e7 but
timing that is important
and i like this move by the way by duda
with a5 because if he had not played a5
white wanted to play c3 but probably
wouldn't be four and then c3 so as not
to drop the pawn on b3
but a5 says hey you're pawn's stuck here
and you have to be
completely sure that c3 works otherwise
you give me a pawn in front of your king
and then my knight can back up to c5
that may not work out the way you
intended to so
i like that duda played a5 it also gives
him the possibility to play a4 himself
to try to break open this a file at all
cost and
rook g2 interesting choice i i guess
he's just
preemptively defending here so he can
put his bishop on d5
all right but now we're getting back to
this queen eight six i
the pawn on upon on d6 is weak
what about bishop c4 is that
there's still b5 miraculously because if
bishop d5
is rook takes g3 distracting your rook
from this square
and uh that's a big point that's a big
point
it looks like you're right although
although robert although hmm oh i see
what you should
do you're trying to continue this line
yes
king a2 very important so you don't take
with check and i think i take on d1
rather than taking on g3 because if i
take on g3 at the end of this i see
you're going to check this was the point
this was the point i was checking out
like this looks this is over we're just
winning in this position
so you cannot do that and i'm sure he's
calculating
wait bishop c4 is on the board oh so
this might happen but this is c4 is on
the board this is the
high class trickery now are we so what's
happening here queen 86 does not
work and i think if bishop f7 there's
like rook g7 maybe like
barely keeping things together i'm not
convinced that's clearly i would have
been a queen h6 in that position but
then i'm gonna take your bishop but
you're gonna take my bishop and i don't
have a queen
queen to line up on the g line that
would win you're right so what would i
do
here would i back up and then just back
up just
threatened just to take and start
harassing you yeah this is just
it's just good your king on a2 is
somehow safe and the king on
h8 doesn't look so safe is that true a4
is coming though
a4 if bishop yeah you're right
oh my gosh you have to move the bishop
first but eight this is too complex man
yes
that's what i'm saying i don't know and
b5 is on the board bishop d5
on the board and we are there we are
there folks
35 sec both players at only half a
minute
probably with a little bit of an edge
but this is duda's chance he is
ferociously calculating rook takes on g3
it feels like it's now or never because
c3 is coming next c3 is coming next
and then his knight is going to get
chased and white is going to say yes
thank you very much
let's maybe even switch to the d line
whatever it is it feels like he needs to
just play
he's he's backed up he's he's blinked he
did not play the move
and he's played a4 instead deciding on
this line i feel like see
take on a4 and play c3 robert looks like
the right way to go here
maybe you take this rook g3 so i mean
he's tricking him into taking on a4
so that when his queen gets to c2 out to
a4
nasty point indeed that's a very nasty
point
and instead he's played rook c1 oh he
wants to take with the pawn because the
bishop
covers the a8 square which means you're
never getting your rook into the attack
to make me
that's such a strong bishop but that
knight on d4 is also good
white for choice now the knight on d4
yes the bishop but i gotta like
white here as black is congested and now
the king to g7
interrupting the play where's that king
going
i think he just needed to make a move
and here he goes queen to c3
and queen c7 and now they're flying
i'm not sure anybody's winning here rook
siete is
the king is on eight six what
rookie come on now this is not real
no way you're surviving this position
can you be queen c7 a trade
i think they're just blitzing now
they're not sure what's happening at all
what's this oh my gosh here comes the
king this is dude his game
g4 is a bad move g4 was definitely a bad
move it did
not it was not correct but you know what
right around now it doesn't matter what
correct
is because they're just blitzing two
seconds left three seconds both sides
just
go just going down with no time on the
clock
it's winning for black though knight g3
knight takes e4 he can just win the pawn
directly
and just a threat and there he goes and
he's trying he's picked off a pawn
and due to using now the one second
increment that he's got
will he be able to do it one second two
seconds left
he's gotta move he's gotta move he's
worried about giving up this b5 pawn so
he should keep that pawn you want pawns
on both sides he breaks open the
position now he's a past e pawn this is
it maurice this is
definitely good and there he goes knight
attacking and he's gonna pick off the
pawn
and now fabi with one last chance but
it's not gonna be enough because the e
pawn
is also passed and this is terrible the
pawn will push b-pawn will push he's got
too many things he's got to deal with
does fabi and oh the knight on e4
guarding the critical point and now big
time trouble
is he threatening to take bobby has one
chance but no he's too slow
islam amazing
save by duda he needed that game robert
badly and he got he still looks like
he's in the same mood he's been the
entire time
barely kind of moving his body just kind
of there
and that was huge though that was really
important for him just to prove that he
can beat fabian
he knows he can he's done it before but
in this match fabiano has been
the more dominant two players and we're
back to this french
and queen of b6 because the paul went to
a3 so that was the big difference
due to realizing he doesn't like these
positions with black kids before
maurice are we gonna see d4 what
come on come on you know what the
problem is they don't get breaks
they don't get breaks that where they
can their second on the side could say
hey hey next time you get this position
you can play d4
i mean they just don't get those breaks
and
maybe they're seeing something that we
don't see robert we we ourselves we're
not a
100 percent clear maybe they're seeing
some deep
2 800 3000 chests that we're not aware
of
but d4 does look like a really good move
in that position
i think that after into going to three
minute portion
when they can look over their openings a
bit you know take a quick breather
then we'll start seeing fabi going for
d4 much more likely but
if duda decides that it's a position he
wants to play again because fabi hasn't
uh hasn't probably won two games with
black already
he has yeah i mean so you
two both games in the french they're
discussing this french again dude i
might say it's time to leave this french
this french is hitting me in the head
the french are cheering as it looks like
black has done well both times although
i remember this last time
when he was able to play the move b4 and
get his queen of h4
and get some stuff we were liking white
a lot
and here comes b4 himself remember we
said b4 was
the idea for white and bobby said i
don't want to see that again that was
annoying so let me get this move in
myself
before good shot get your play quickly
right you can't not afford to have dude
i just go on the king side like you did
the last time
you need to open some stuff up here and
so b4 he wanted to take so his knight
could have captured on b4 and gone after
this bishop on d3
but uh this is smart by due to not
taking on b4 allowing black take on a3
trying to keep it close but finally
maurice we see d4
we see the bishop on b7 come alive and
how to prove it though yes we like that
bishop now
but is it going to amount to much or is
white about to play knight h5
bring the queen in and this poor king on
g8 is about to get made it
okay uh look yeah he's don't get too
excited okay we're gonna deal with that
right now he said
let me bring my knight back to e7 and
then when i'm ready i'm gonna
kill your piece on d3 when your queen
lands on g
about to land on g3 so i can play knight
f5 instantly
at the same moment the exact moment
your knight gets to your queen gets to
g3
so knight h5 will be bent by now it
takes d3
and then let's keep it going on the
queen side that's what five he's after
because he's ready with the knight f5
defense his bishop is beautiful
he's stopped knight e4 i'm liking black
black's done everything he wanted this
is why we want to play d4 robert
this is the reason we wanted to play d4
he got it in
he's got b4 in he's got the bishop on d3
on the threat
bishop's beautiful dag you know i think
black's okay
yeah and i res i was in my temper
tantrum that i had earlier that he
didn't play d4
maybe he just knows his line better than
i do and he's just saying i can wait if
you know i can get d4 in my own time
and here it just looks so nice for black
the pieces are
very strong here this knight at some
point consider coming to d5
into e3 but of course the d4 pawn will
be hanging in many of these lines
but even bishop takes f3 maurice and
then knight to d5 bring this knight into
these dark squares
it feels like black is the one first to
the punch
it's very fluid right now it's hard for
me to give up my bishop on the long
diagonal in this way
especially since that knight on f3 he's
only doing one little bit of work
but look at this now
let me tell you i would very much not
have gone after the a-pawn
in this case look at fabi said i don't
believe your attack
and knight h4 on the board is i don't
believe you i think i can just snack a
rooney on this pawn on a3
and what attack do you have are you
mating me with f5
and company
i'd be scared i'm just saying i
personally would be scared
having my queen with this kind of
excursion
on the other side of the board when the
guy is trying to kill me
you're also opening yourself up to
discoveries from the uh enough memories
of queen a3
then knight h5 and once i play queen g3
i'm not only threatening mate i'm
throwing bishop h7 check
thank you for your queen on a3 and if
you take on d3 in comes the rook
with tempo sliding over to g3 as well
and that looks like a problem
this is a whole this whole excursion
looked like a problem putting a queen on
b2
that you know they say when you when
you're trying to win
a pawn when you go to win material it
takes three moves the move it took to
attack
queen b2 the move it took to take queen
takes a3
and the move it takes to get your queen
out of there anywhere you want
all right that's three home moves you
give somebody so
dude i said okay knight h4 i'm thinking
that you know that's your attacking move
you're gonna take i'm like knight h5
that's my second move and you can make
some queen move queen g3 thanks for the
three free moves i'm on the attack i'm
threatening sax i'm after you
so this is a really delicate moment for
fabie dropping that queen on b2
and and and now he's played rook to c8
clearly he's not taking an a3 pawn he's
got to get
counter play before white winds up like
a mike tyson punch
and knocks you out you know it felt like
one of those psychological experiments
maurice where
you put some candy in front of a kid and
they're not supposed to take it right a3
was the candy
but the cameras are on yellow the
marshmallow experiment we're watching
you don't want a3 you want to wait you
want to be patient and rook c8
lines up on the c2 pawn because that's
the much better pawn to munch on here
so if he can't take this bishop and take
on c2 that opens up the entire second
rank and the bishop on b7 comes alive
with a rook getting down c2 into the
attack i hear you talking i hear you
talking robert but
i'm feeling like something better
happened real quick
because the knight just landed on h5 and
their their guns
are about to be aimed at black's head
queen g3 is coming on the next move the
question is
is knight takes playable knight takes
queen to g3 looks like the intermezzo
you got to toss in there
and then g6 this looks like what has to
happen
and is this what's on the board looks
like it's on the board the game position
and now is black okay
this is the question and i can end up on
f6 but is it just a lonely
night with no one else joining the party
by the way rook b1
rook b1 is yet another move to be
well wait a second wait rook b1 is met
by
by oh it's blacks during the move so
rook b1 was an additional threat
right rupee one was an additional threat
so he had to get his bishop out of there
and now does white have a blow
maybe white has nothing this is what
he's calculated that white doesn't have
anything and that
bishop is going to be superior to both
those knights sitting on the side of the
board
and his knight and h4 sort of has to
stay here because you do not want to
allow knight f5
as that knight hits the queen and also
enters the e3 square so
knight f6 as you're suggesting and i
agree with you is just a check
right my king can just go to h8 or g7
and unless you can follow up
very quickly with your queen
infiltrating then you're not getting
what you're you came for yeah the
problem is
that white's rooks are not doing
anything i mean the rooks need to be
planted somewhere but the window of the
attack
that that attack window on the you look
on the on that king side
it's so small there are no vectors
leading toward that black key
and i don't have six congratulations but
nobody else to join the party
so this this night will be its own
lonesome
like a covid attack on it or something
that's telling you know nothing going on
i'm telling you this position looks fine
for black
he's okay he's estimated it quite well
no problems here the question for white
is will he let black start to wind up
anything
there's a rook c3 that might happen is
it rook c2 that might happen
and white has no penetration points
nowhere
nowhere brook b6 who cares what do you
do as white
maurice it's sad but what i'm thinking
about is knight d7 knight b6 just so i
can get this bishop off the board like i
was just
playing defense i was like let me bring
a knight with a temple on your rook and
then bring my knight to b6
with a shot on your rook and your bishop
but he plays knight e4 which
does limit the scope of the bishop but
you can even
consider at some point taking and
bringing this rook down to c3 and
going after this queen what do you mean
at some point
right away that was a possibility right
on the board it was
bishop bishop take looked like an idea
the problem is
it does give white control of the f5
square
right that's what he just didn't want to
give him any chance of being able to
build
on the attack because then the pawn is
on e4 then he could play for f5 and
there's some initiative there
i'm gonna give him nothing like no
nothing for you
no food for you let's just keep the
attack limited night on a great square
d6 robert
but what's the deal am i not liking rook
c2 here like so
is there f5 that's what i was wondering
because f5 you cannot oh there it comes
if queen takes g3 you throw an f6 check
into metro very important move
and if you take i take with my knight
thank you very much because after knight
takes f5
your pawn is pinned and i win your queen
so f5
was played i don't i don't get it why
not trade queens let you get that move
and now uh the knight can can find
multiple squares for one c6 hits your
pawn
but d5 also hello e3 is coming
and all your f5 f6 move did was block up
the position now you could dream about
an
end game this is very important to note
an end game that might be
better for white because the black king
is frozen
that's why i wanted to try to work on
that e5 pawn and there he goes he's
moved his rook off the line so he can go
after it
but suddenly there's some back rank
issues in the position that
that white is trying to cook up and this
is actually very difficult for black
with 16 seconds left both sides in time
trouble
i think it's very hard for both to play
and look at fabiano very smartly
going for this g2 is it rookie 194
that's me it's mate rookie one knight g4
knight f2 it's over
it's over he blundered rook he should
have moved his knight first he blundered
rook down
and fabi stole the game look at that
stunned look
on dude his face he was mr cool before
this but that stunned looking probably
with a half a smirk there
as rook b8 blundered the back ring and
as you pointed out he spotted the mate
as quickly as you did robert knight g4
hello
knight f2 your king can't go anywhere
mott
on the board what a steal by fabi
and that's just the kind of form he's in
today right they you know
people don't really believe so much in
luck and chess right if he can continue
putting the pressure on duda
it's because of that that dude is making
mistakes and honestly fabi had
the better of the position you said it
clearly maurice the pawn in f6
it looks very nice but it's not
amounting to as much as
it would if you could actually create an
attack and the attack was too slow
fabi steals the point i think that duda
has been too slow
let's be real duda has not been able to
play incisively
and get a lead on the clock we have not
seen him get a minute lead
40 seconds even it's fabi every single
game
and if bobby continues to do that game
after game after game
keep that edge on the clock dude is in
trouble and what's this position d4 this
must be some theory but look at dude
he's shaking his head
his eyes i mean he's glazed over he's
not happy
right now fabi with a 4-1 score now it's
smart
was it smart chess that said
fabio would only get four points because
he's got four right now
he's got four i mean the score was
supposed to be five to four
five he's got four dude would have to
win the next four games in a row who
wants to take
that bet right now um i don't think so
the way fabi's playing the way dude is
not getting his quick leads on the clock
uh this is not great but
this last sequence tricky tricky
what is going on here is black just much
better
i believe so rook d8 can pile up more
pressure on this pin
piece there is c3 so let's count
we have one two three attackers on this
d4 knight
and there are three defenders so if we
can remove one defender
we win this game is there a way to do
that because white will try to play c3
next so robert but the knight on the
knight on
f6 can prance i mean knight g4 i'm
i'm scared as scared like look at this
knight
what the heck i mean this is this is
dangerous
this is pure preparation this is pure
preparation and fabi stumbled right into
one of judah's positions
this right here looks like clean prep
pure as ever for black you will not see
this position happen again
in this match it's not gonna bobby's out
of this one
he's just following her into something
and doing it just what the doctor
ordered for duda
just what the doctor ordered i'm i'm
with you the game is not over of course
but on knight f2
isn't that just there might be some
knight c6 and queen g7 stuff but at the
very least knight f2
forks these rooks here and that spells
trouble for
what if he starts with knight takes d
knight takes d4
maybe he's over a knight e6
maybe he's over a knight e6 but i don't
buy that either i mean i just
i don't believe it can can black even
castle queenside here
[Laughter]
stop it oh my goodness that looks awful
i it just pins the knight and then the
rook can't move because then the night
is lost here so
it's over actually it just adds another
attacker you can't protect it really
does
it's over it just shut the whole thing
down pure opening prep
dude needed this game badly due to
neither this game and fabi is normally
the one
who falls for who traps people in these
things he's playing
d8 instead leaving his king in the
middle after all you cannot move the
knight
because of what looks to be rook d1 i
mean unless
unless there's a trick of some is 96
possible robert or am i just dreaming
fantasizing yeah i don't believe in
myself but let's play it what else are
you going to do you're going to resign
otherwise
what happens with 96 rook d1 and you
have to
let's play knight f1 i'm just going to
try to get my bishop in the game
and now if i take you have queen g7 i
bishop d4 and that's that
okay now we cleared the cobwebs that's
the finish of that
so we got the story right doesn't work
doesn't work
can't do it it's over this is busted
but i i'm with you though that is the
best chance that fabi has even though
judah has way too much time to fall for
some sort of trap there there's
something funny robert sorry
play the same line again 96 yeah rook d1
bishop c1
okay oh it's just a stop yeah just a
joke takes on e6 queen g7
and bishop d4 and it's still mate on b2
because of the pin
so it doesn't help at all that's mate on
the board
chess sometimes has a sense of humor and
fabi's not going to find this one very
funny no he's not the one laughing here
so uh this is down a piece the knight is
pinned and what do you think if you're
fabi you've out to a 4-1 lead it's about
t-42
do you just spend the rest of your time
calming yourself down do you think he
needs to just like
take a breath here losing with the white
pieces is never fun
he thinks and this is what he does right
now the clock is ticking
clearly he could just resign and play
the next game but what he needs to do
and what he might be doing right now is
he's thinking all right what went wrong
here in this opening
let me work it out right now i'm going
to be playing the french next game
that's fine
but what went wrong here and he's using
this this time
doing the beth harmon thing he could be
looking on the ceiling right now going
hmm
what am i what did i do where was the
trap how will i play differently next
time
how will i improve okay got it and when
that has settled in his system
he'll make some random move like 96 and
then he'll give up the game but this is
out
no question about it after pawn takes
there's no move yeah as we pointed out
this bishop is not guarding b2 it just
isn't
and duda probably will not sleep on this
fact
it would be stunning if he did but no
after queen takes
on g7 he missed it uh well the thing is
the knight could take on d4 i guess but
he's just winning the bishop one f1 so
he just
he went for a different winning plan
gotcha
but yeah i also was like wait oh but
rook f8 let me just take this because
queen e6 is one check
and i think this is actually an
important moment for our viewers
because queen e6 would scare most of us
because it does look worrisome when your
king's in the center you get a check
but if we get this check 97 blocks a
knight is a great defender it takes away
your remaining checks for your
queen and now i'm offering a queen trade
wall up an entire row
uh that was really nice of you to offer
a queen trade while up a rook you're
such a nice guy
offering a queen tray i'm glad you think
i'm a nice guy maurice we've been
friends for a long time
[Music]
bishop a3
oh so unnecessary but still so strong
so not nice so not nice
don't move the 97 now though because
then you drop your queen
uh you got no pieces to attack with
white is checking with one piece
there's nothing to attack with uh it was
it was a good time to resign before this
he could have he could have definitely
just stopped the clock uh
right now uh is he just done an exchange
at the moment
it is in exchange points it's in
exchange for
three so he's somehow trying to finagle
some kind of attack
but right now queen b2 mate is a threat
so you got to deal with that
b3 looks like it runs into queen e3
yeah just for fun queen e3
queen d4 come on man
be nice some respect
okay white should have resigned a long
time ago so this
this does allow queen d5 check to try to
keep the game going and maybe queen e3
would have been met by queen d5
check as well i'll bring it up we'll
bring it up oh my goodness
yeah maybe queen e3 was queen i think is
losing
clearly queen d5 check here forcing rook
takes queen
then bishop takes e3 but back down with
check and then give us the f1 piece
i mean it was over all kinds of
different ways so it didn't matter
but fabi as i said in for me
i have i have a mentality especially if
it's a match situation like this
but it's but in particular you do this
in tournaments as well
settle yourself settle yourself take
time to settle yourself
and what fabi did taking that long break
i hope he spent time settling himself i
don't think he should have made any more
moves
i think he should have accepted the
situation was bad forget it everybody's
making moves
make them quickly but the key thing was
to settle yourself
settle your brain and get ready for this
for the next game after this one say
how should i have played now we're
seeing a new french twist
as fabias chased duda
out of the line that he was playing yeah
he put
a5 instead of a6 and b5 but this pawn
was on c3 so it's a different line
all the way back here because the knight
had been on c3 f4
knight f3 have been played but knight c
to e2 allows you to create this pawn
chain so that's why
things are a little different here so he
did you like that when you chase
somebody out of the line that they were
playing
and say okay go to something else maybe
your secondary line
that you haven't prepared as well as a
backup line so fabi feeling good about
that for sure
duda in the meantime has to settle
things down he doesn't seem to have an
alternative
e4 what what to do so he's going
into these french positions
straightforward and hoping that he gets
some play
but at least he's settled the match
robert it is four to two at the moment
so he was getting blown out 3-0 felt
horrible
4-2 on the other hand a bit different
feel
in this and by the way how badly is
white doing in this match
not well not well at all right
i mean white sounds like this the score
might be four to two white
i'm i'm not sure exactly what the
numbers won
three wins for black because jkd just
won with black and fobby's won two games
the black so at the very least is three
to three
so i think fobby won three games with
black
because he mated him in that last french
he won the first two french's
and he made it have been the last french
that's four two you're right three so
four for black yeah
i'd say blacks black's doing well but
hold on what is the other game that duda
won
dude just one with black what was the
other game he won did he win
why am i forgetting the game he beat
fabi he also won black in games he also
won
it's 5-1 black right now it's 5-1
black is rolling in this match
unbelievable
man don't want to have the white pieces
incredible so far in the match and black
by the way in this position also looks
good
yeah this rook on h3 you need to sort of
get the sacrifice going take on h7
knight g5
all this kind of stuff but i'm pretty
positive fabi will not allow that i
wouldn't be surprised to see him like
f5 played to close down the king side
and i'm not even sure bishop h7 works i
just know the idea
i'm fearful of it i do not want to allow
it
yeah i hear you i hear you and it's got
to be calculated
in every single move right now dude with
a little bit of edge
on the clock as he's got in a complex
position this is a critical game
folks this is a critical game fabi
breaks through and goes up
five to two uh he will
almost surely win this portion
almost surely win this portion so this
is a critical game we see
that there's only 20 minutes and change
left in this portion of the match that's
two more
blitz games after this matter of fact he
may be lucky to get
the second one in well i guess he would
say yeah they're two more after this
so that's this is a critical moment for
duda and fabio decided
he didn't want to see any bishop 87
sacrifices get rid of that stupid bishop
on d3 and just play chess here his
bishop
can i love that maneuver you pointed out
his bishop can go
back and what just happened so bishop
bishop
to attack this pawn and the knight was
in the way so he dropped the knight back
to a8
to defend it with the queen man i hate
moves like that me too
oh really you like you can have my pawn
i hate moves like that my goodness did
he really have to play that move
probably not couldn't he play yeah i
guess bishop b4 looks lame also but
i like that
i mean it seems seems preferable no i
mean i i don't know i just
i hate moves like knight a just to
defend not only do you put your knight
on a horrible square you're not can't
even move
right for starters and your queen is
tethered
i mean it just feels like you gave a
couple of moves up but
black might just be holding the position
together you made this point about the
bishop being able to switch diagonals
from d7 to e8 to the g6 squared that's
not going to happen
i'm starting to like white i'm starting
to like white now it feels as though
black
must play for b5 must
must play for b5 at some point i don't
know how he's going to get it
but he's going to have to get some kind
of play and knight back to e2 i'm not
sure where that knight is going uh
there to stop your plan b5 is going to
happen at some point
it can't happen now unfortunately
because the a5 pawn will hang
with the rook on that square so he's
played b6 and now he's got he's got a 2
whoa i was saying he's got a tortuous
path to his night getting in the game
but g4 on the board and duda
feeling the confidence now trying to
make the big comeback robert
man that is a rambunctious
ambitious audacious move it's amazing
how the position went from looking good
for black to a knight being on a8 and
white
just attacking with a free hand so
finally i don't have to address
these moments here because it's just
clearly good for what you have a great
spatial advantage
your rook on h3 suddenly very useful can
come to g3 and play g5
you want to break open the king side
over here i mean king f2 can be played
bringing this rook to g1
what's going on by the way the move
knight takes d3
is looking terrible right now yeah it
just caused pure flow for white
queen went to d3 bishop goes to d2 and
white is able to just do a quick
maneuver knight back and trolley g4
knight takes is looking awful as an
exchange it looks solid but the bishop
on d7
that's supposed to say look thanks for
your bishop
i'm gonna use the bishop i now have to
show you why
the bishops are strong but bishop on d7
sucks i mean
sucks the knight on c7 horrible
white just has all this space now all
that said
white still has to find out how to to
bash black's headed it's
it's still not easy to make progress
here
without giving up some kind of energy to
black and there you go rook c1
not a move i'd want to play because it
might potentially lead to trades on the
c
line but where does your knight go and
as soon as i said it then i went to e8
it doesn't have a future there but he's
looking the trade well i didn't like
rook c1 because
when aside lacks space you want to trade
so black doesn't really have much room
to breathe
and now if you can trade along the c
file and maybe get that b5 move in
even if that costs you a pawn you need
to get your pieces active
uh but on the other side of things how
is white crashing through are you going
to play g5 that may open up the f file
and there's a rook on a f8
that will be happy about that will you
play f5 but that could collapse your
center on the e5 score and the f5 square
so
it's not that easy for dude to crash
through but trading pieces on the queen
side
doesn't feel helpful for him did not
feel rook c1 i totally agree with you
didn't why is your rook on c1 we
threaten the sack on c7 like
what's the point it was an empty move he
played it quickly and
he had a minute lead on the clock we
were talking about how much time he
needs to start getting an edge on the
clock
and he blew it in that moment and now
fabi gets a chance to trade the queen is
on g6
it looks part trying to do something but
i'm not sure what it's threatening
i'm not sure the point at all in fact
i'm not now though
what is the counter play for fabies now
said
knight to c7 he's headed to the move
bishop e8 if needed get your queen out
of there
that that trade on a c file did wonders
for black's position absolute wonders
and it's only getting better on every
move
it really is because even if the eval
bar says white is still doing well
it's so much easier to play for black
you have a sigh of relief your pieces
are coming out
and now taking on f6 he's deciding how
he wants to do that rook takes f6
hits the queen that's great but it also
makes the rook vulnerable to a quick g5
which will blast open the position
time he moved his rook back he heard you
he heard you
i there's gonna be a bishop before check
at some point you know he wanted to play
knight a six knight b4 is another idea
but all of this is too slow and now here
comes the knight to the e5 square i
would gift you my
my bishop on d7 if you wanted it if you
want it please
take it it's all yours here i would play
b5 and close my eyes just please
just let's get something going even
though i'm probably busted
and here g5 on the board okay duda has
figured out
how to pry open that side of the board
look at this attack
and actually a big problem reese is this
bishop is hanging because
hgfg you can't take on g5 because the
end the line
the bishop on d7 hangs once the queen
has to move out the way that's a big
issue for fabiano so maybe bishop e8 was
necessary probably down to seven
seconds only on the clock his clock is
in precarious territory with duda with
55 seconds
and a raging attack it's bad maybe
bishop e8 instead of b5 was
much better now that we look at it but
here the knight has been chopped off the
board white is just
owning this position at the moment
thanks to the bishop on d7 and the
knight on c7
as the position opens up fatherly with
pure desperation
taking on a4 and praying that he's not
dying on the other side
but this looks terrible yeah rook f7 h7
check is important he goes 98 but even h
takes an
h6 and h7 mate is coming it's just over
it's just no way to fight back and
there it is a big time win for
with white by the way for duda
in that game absolutely huge i'm gonna
bring up that moment
because it's very instructive by you
maurice saying that capturing on d3
releasing that tension
made all of white's development very
easy
because right here yes there was the
attack on the h7 pawn we talked about
that
you can play f5 to stop it but bishop d2
is not
possible when the bishop's on d3 because
the queen needs to defend it but after
trading here
look at how easy it was for white to
develop everything protect the queen
side attack and then you had a free hand
over on the king side so you're right
maurice taking on d3 i believe that was
an inaccuracy a subtle one at first
glance but it cost
fabiano the game well i have a rule that
i tell my students
that the three f's to trading it should
be
forced it should be forced
or fantastic forced or fantastic
or else it's going to be well you know
the other f
all right that's my theory when i talk
about the three f's of trading
and fabi felt it in that position did
not trade
it wasn't forced it wasn't fantastic so
hey you know what fabi felt that
and uh he went down in that game here we
see duda going back into this line
that got him so much love and bobby's
certainly switching it up a little bit
with a pawn sacrifice on e4
temporarily but now looks like he'll win
his pawn back
yeah although i wonder if you take on e4
with some kind of knight b4
hitting c2 hitting a2 it could be quite
tricky here for fabi to deal with
and it's perhaps a good lesson do you
have to take this pawn back right away
can you leave it there start with king
b1 he does that
and say e4 is falling in the very near
future
well uh there's some trickery here
knight g4 is possible preventing you
from taking on e4 right away
and then maybe playing for e3 but that
involves
not castling not getting your bishop in
the game
that could be dangerous that could be
very dangerous trying for this idea
with no development but it looks it does
look possible
white hopes to be able to take and he's
done it
on the board queen g3 could even i was
gonna say bishop c5 but i forgot there's
a knight on b3 covering the square you'd
love to play bishop c5
and bishop takes b3 no that's too much
you can't give up your bishops
and keep your king in the center right
so here we go
in this this is a dynamic moment as
queen g3 has been played
and robert you and i played a blitz game
the last game we ever played we played a
blitz game for charity
uh if you remember that was it for
children's cancer yeah right there was a
charity we played in and we played an
amazing blitz game i mean it was
we had so much fun in that game
fantastic game you got me
but the critical moment that you
mentioned
was taking a pawn that was blocking up
the position i don't know if you
remember the game at all
when i when i took a pawn that was
blocking up your play
and sometimes you have to leave those
parts alone and say i'm just going to go
for other stuff
and i re i just got the pawn back in a
moment when i shouldn't have
and this kind of situation probably said
you know what you can even save your
stinking pawn you want to play f5 right
now
go ahead go ahead i'm with you but your
pieces
will feel a little blockage bishop e2 is
coming
and i'm just going to get free play i'm
going for free play there hitting your
knight
threatening and f5 is on the board this
contentious position now by the way
bishop e2h5 is playable will he play
h5 first as white or will he hit the
bishop e2 move
first so all this is what fabi's looking
at trying to figure out what's the right
way to flow here because bishop e2h5
looks like you're never stopping these
guys from being
in the position so maybe he has to play
h5 himself so he can play bishop b2 on
the next move
well there's got to be something because
i see three uh 0.3 is the evaluation for
white
so i'm trying to find what it is is
there some kind of knight okay
nuance moves are not what the computer
believes in when
it's giving this kind of evaluation
night
i really want to play knight d5 to get
my knight in and force you to take me
but bishop v2 played still at plus one
and a half so clearly still good for
white but
so there was something bigger is what
we're saying something bigger was on the
board
that may have knocked him out but he's
playing the way i wanted to play with
this kind of maneuver bishop
and here's the deal you cannot develop
your bishop
on f8 without some pain you do have to
calculate there nicely king to f7
some tactics are starting to float here
man what is happening
it feels like a queen g6 weird
you know you know what i'm talking about
robert some bizarro tactics
might start appearing on the board even
queen
g5 with the idea of g4 wait wait
there's this crate this this is some
sick stuff i want my knights to migrate
over there as well
but i don't see how to hit yet
yeah i didn't mean queen g6 right now i
meant
the logical follow-up to an attack that
ends up with such a
such a crazy idea but some things some
things are footy here how does white
make progress robert
i'm looking at these queenside dark
scores as well it's like you have such
good control on this diagonal here
that oh he's setting it up he's
definitely setting up a knight a4
hop into b6 and not only can you go to
b6 this knight can come into c5 you want
to chop down this bishop on e6
which is defending the light squares and
queen f2 it does open up your g4 move
maurice that one looks actually very
tempting next
because the king on f7 is not happy to
see a queen in its line of sight
well when you look at a position the
first thing you have to do is look at
your pawn breaks
because pieces normally unless they
sacrifice like the crazy queen g6
sacrifice i pointed out
pieces normally cannot enter positions
because pawns are guarding squares
so the only thing that you look for the
main thing that you look for to compete
to combat those pawns restricting your
play are pawn breaks
so g4 is a natural pawn break h6 isn't
because g6
and black shuts the position down but g4
is a natural one
otherwise you have to find out squares
for your pieces where can they penetrate
and you pointed out robert the b6 square
you spotted the c5 square you spotted
those are key squares in the position
that you can get to if you look around
you can scan the board very quickly and
realize
you don't have anywhere else to put your
pieces you might play bishop d6
trade off this dark squared bishop and
then maybe double rooks on the d-line
even after all that you're wondering
well if i could get that if i could get
that for free
but he's able to root d8 and start
challenging that so those posts are not
great what we're looking for are pawn
breaks
like a g4 move open up the game and then
try
to smash your opponent that's what he's
looking for in this position right now
and that's what duda is starting to
analyze what do i do about this
bishop to e7 looks like the most natural
move but he's worried about g4 and he
spent
so much time on the clock while we've
been speaking that he's down
under a minute this is not good
i don't care what the position is and
he's played h6
oh he wants that queen g6 to have and
he's saying i'm going to play h6
and i don't fully comprehend what it
does like
there was nothing coming to g5 at least
now that i'm seeing so h6
it got me real excited and what's
there's some bizarre am i am i spooking
on some
oh you played g4 i mean yeah sure i i
had a bizarre tactical idea robert i put
my queen
on nah it's too crazy forget it i'm not
going to talk about it
i wanted to spawn queen on g6 and sack
my queen on an f7 bishop with bishop c4
check
maybe mating depending on what you do
but it was the idea is so fanciful it's
not worth even
craziness talking about but here we go
we have this position here
he's played this g4 move and he's taken
and put his king
nestled in this cubbyhole but he is down
two rooks for my count at the moment
black has a rook and a rook on h8 these
pieces are not working
but how does white take advantage of the
moment bishop the bishop is going to
come
to the e7 square and look at this he's
saying i'm going to go after your e4
pawn
i want the pawn your king as long as
you're down a rook i'm not down two
pawns
as long as you're down the rook your
rook on h8 i'm not down material
yet i understand the move h6 a lot more
now he wanted to prevent bishop g5
in the event of g4 because it makes
white's life more difficult to
recapture these pawns but e4 is what the
target is
and 30 seconds for black fabiano's
plenty of time he has a minute and 43
seconds
he can calculate now 20 about to be 20
seconds for black your kings on g8 your
rooks are not connected
you've got no development or
coordination i think that this should be
a conversion for fobby yeah over this is
over
this is blunder territory this is what
we're sniffing
he just needs to to find moves on every
move fabi that's just like
next on to the next one on to the next
one on to the next one
knight takes e4 what you dared you
dare take on h5 i mean should i be
sacking on h5 right now
bishop bishop d6 head ooh i almost
blunted i want to go knight
b to c5 to bring another piece in but
what have you sack on h5
now in employee knight c5 i just feel
like this must be an
overwhelming attack i cannot believe he
survives this position
i would i have a hard time imagining
that would be the case here and
i'm also looking at this g4 rookie one
knight f6 kind of stuff happening
yes yes i feel you i like it i like it
all of it looks good there's some killer
there's but the engine's saying it's
equal
so we're we're getting out of hand with
all our ideas
but i don't think black defends this
position and he's played my idea
of sacking on h5 i'm not sure it's any
good he
is up a rook at the moment folks the
king
can't get out yet but is is he crashing
through he has no
bishop c4 because of bishop f7 so yeah
did
what's the next move here is it one is
possible too
queen b3 to take b7 is uh
greedy did he take on f8 he did that is
the last thing i would have done
that isn't like that would have been out
of but that wouldn't have been even in
my my purview
i wouldn't would have seen that move
take it on it you just you just
facilitated the defensive setup
okay maybe he's thinking well rook to d7
and eight seconds left and you know
there's something
always going to be cooking in a position
like this bishop c4 what you got
i really want to get knight f6 after
because when the king's on h7 the g pawn
is pinned but the queen defends f6 so
you just need to
coordinate this so queen c3 is always a
possibility lining up for knight of six
but now
yeah what was a3 i don't know i don't
know you can't be giving the guy free
moves though just go for it
and now now king age seven and it looks
as though black is defending
as the bishop cannot get to d3 and black
is
putting up a wall eight seconds left for
fabi while we've been talking
unbelievable fabian spent all this time
and he's not figured it out
knight to e6 queen f5 and the moves are
coming fast and furious
robert this is good for black this is
great for black and it's hard to play
for both sides of two seconds for fobby
rookie fate played
king a2 the a6 pawn can be captured but
that g pawn is too
wait it's gone as soon as i said it's
too strong here's quimby one coming
by the trade and it's one second they're
playing on
increment only but it's duda with a time
edge can
fabi possibly survive as moves are just
being played
that that check gotta respond two
seconds and now
he's blockaded he's got a knight g5 idea
eventually but this is bad
no this is awful it's just winning yeah
the rook is too strong for the minor
pieces up in the night's been trapped
the knight's been trapped
duda pulls it off you know what i hate
about that
maurice look at the score and the
smarter chess prediction was five to
four
in duda's favor and you were saying
dude is not winning four in a row he's
won three in a row and if duda wins this
game
smarter chess somehow is correct
no he didn't win three in a row he won
he won four out of the last
three out of the last four because it
was 3-1 it was 3-0 then it was 3-1 then
it was 41.
yeah he's won three in a row it was four
to one then it was
no it's four isn't it four to three
right now is it four it's four four
what what where have i been
unbelievable it is four wow
wow dude to putting it together
amazing i thought he had only won three
out of the last four he's actually won
those three in a row and the and smart
chess
yeah making making itself look super
smart
if bobby loses his game and goes down
5-4 the final score will be dominant
no question about it duda is on a roll
right now
fabi fabi did not win a position he
should have won
absolutely and now things are looking
bad
it should not be even he was up 3-0 the
score should not be either
and have to give a nod to duda because
he was in immense time trouble his king
was on g8 his
pieces were not coordinated at all and
yet he survived long enough to get fobby
in time trouble as well
it was hard to find a knockout punch and
that's why he was able to win that game
and
we have another french maurice here
different position to be sure
and instead of our typical uh setup that
we've seen time and time again we now
have black with the bishop pair
the bishop on c8 not quite finding a
useful diagonal
for the near future and white is going
to play bishop d3 going to make progress
on the king's side
and it feels like judah's position is
slightly better
what what's this last move he's i guess
he's figured out that bishop takes b5
it was impossible so king f2 and you you
expect from
from black right now b4 and bishop to a6
to resolve this problem of this bishop
and then hope
against hope that there's no attack i
think it's fair to say there's no attack
so time to trade off your bad piece
um he's a little bit worried about the
domination on the sea line however
right and we've seen this is old school
classical domination along that line
uh go back as far as as far as alakine
doing doing the do with the sea lion
i'm remembering some great game remember
that game where alakine
got so much domination on the c file and
then he doubled along the seventh rank
and then he put his
king all the way in and you know the
game i'm talking about yeah who is it is
it
i'm remembering margate is in my head
for some reason but i
can't remember exactly but still you got
to worry about that c
file and so he's decided not to trade
off because he needs to control
the squares along the c file and he
himself has gotten control of that line
and it looks as though favi should be
okay here as
he doesn't have any weaknesses white
does have space
but black has his play as well and one
of the problems i would say is you were
mentioning bishop of a6 and you hear
bishop b5 is possible
but white isn't going to trade the
bishops he'll slide his bishop back to
b1 i imagine
and try to keep the attack alive on the
h7 square and f5 is coming in the future
i don't see how black seizes active play
whereas white's progress is much more
manageable to my eyes and i think fabi
he's doing fine
but b3 just a3 lock that thing up lock
that side of the board up don't allow
black to crash through and it feels like
white's path
just easy to see all right well here we
go
spatial advantage uh trade-offs and
pieces
the attack becomes a lot less likely now
and
the issue really is going to come down
to
what is either side going to do i would
say this position
or the gm level super gm level
especially should be drawn
uh doesn't look doesn't look like
there's real play here
you make a good point robert about black
not having anything serious
along that line black does have that c2
point so
white has to be careful for that but
again bishop to b5 which looks like an
auto move by the way
then bishop back to b1 and now rook c2
still does nothing how does he get
played as black given that
white is going to get his little action
going
that's real i think it's
i don't see a way to stop white's
variety of plans f5 looks strong
at some point knight g5 maybe next
because if you ever take on g5
h takes no no no your h file is a
disaster so
i'm worried for fabi here and i cannot
believe i'm saying this after the start
that he had
smarter chess i don't know how he does
it don't know how he gets these
predictions
and makes them accurate but dude is well
on his way to a 5-4
lead and a victory in the five-minute
portion of this uh
speechless championship match tremendous
comeback and by the way i believe
this last game started with less than a
minute
left for this portion of the event so
getting in yet another game to get even
get the chance to make 5'4 as a number
as opposed to 4-4 so
amazing i mean smart chess is that smart
it goes down to yeah there'll be like a
little time left for him to beat him
that fifth game and probably spending a
lot of time now look
at the clock deficit at the moment
as duda is this is the kind of
expectation we have for duda
is to get fabi in time pressure in the
game
and then put the pressure on some more
and watch fabie crack under pressure and
fabi has a tendency folks
and when he starts losing he doesn't
i mean i got to say it i just got a call
he's a friend of mine but i got to call
it
he sometimes just starts to go backwards
he doesn't stop the bleeding
and and i'm talking about particularly
in rapid and blitz we've seen him do
this
in a lot of rapid and blitz events where
he doesn't stop the bleeding he loses
some confidence
he doesn't write the ship and say look
i'm going to draw a few games and settle
things down
and he's done that right now and a
number three in a row might be four in a
row in a second
if he doesn't figure out what to do
queen c7 was
not a move that suggests that he had
something quick to do because the queen
has nowhere to go queen c2 doesn't do
anything
obviously there's no sacrifice that's
kind of fun and no
just nothing there so what is he
supposed to do here
i don't know i guess he's trying to
queen a5 that looks like you're bringing
all your pieces away from your king
and actually i want to quickly say that
what's been interesting thus far
is while duda has seen the stronger the
two in time scrambles
fabiano has jumped out to a lead on the
clock in the early stages of the game
which could hurt duda in the
three-minute portion when you don't have
as much time because
fabiano's openings have seemed a little
bit better but something about this
french i wonder if fabi will actually
just deviate from it entirely because in
the last bunch of games where
jkd has had the white pieces he has
proven an advantage and king f2
talk about an unexpected move here
maurice is he trying to like go g5 g6
and then say i need the g-file for my
rook
honestly i think he doesn't know what to
do and he's also letting fabi try to
figure it out
i think this is a great strategy 246
left on the clock don't give your
opponent
concrete problems to solve this is evil
this is evil chess
i'm just gonna make a couple of moves
your turn and then i'm gonna make
another couple of moves and
don't mess up i'm not gonna have to try
anything because you might mess up and
help me
yourself so let me just chill let the
seconds tick off your clock
pretty soon bobby's going to be under 30
seconds under 20 seconds
with nothing on the board to do bishop
a5 is nothing look at that
rogue g1 bishop b6 though and rook c4
maybe try to get
get an action on the d4 square and then
it broke d1
i had nothing after that you see he made
he spent a few seconds
and now if duda wants to now he decided
i'm gonna break with f5
rook c4 now you can just play rogue d1
right now and now
what seconds tick away going
off for fabi you see that what to do
what to do he may not be threatened with
anything at the moment but he doesn't
know what to do
and he had to make a move and the
seconds tick down now down to under 20.
this is what i was talking about
duda did not have to do anything just
like bobby make a couple of moves
play play defensively and you're just in
trouble and now you have six
and it's over this is blasting through
perfect strategy
this is lights out as black has nothing
to do here
he can think all he wants duda wins 5'4
smart chess has predicted it
unbelievably okay i'm calling it before
it's over but
this is one of those it's like biden
winning the election it's over
it's done this one is gone and
five to four just like smart chess said
an incredible role by duda
seriously i mean dude has played several
excellent games in a row
he has a great handling of this french
friends from the white side
and fabiano needs to fix his openings
because i don't think he wants to keep
getting into this battle in the french
yeah he's probably avoiding his main
line theory to save that up for
his important can determine whenever
that resumes but maurice before we go to
break
what recommendations would you make to
fabi if he's going to win this match
better faster he cannot his instincts
have left him
i feel something maybe maybe you need
some almonds
maybe some almonds and some raisins
because you feel the energy sucking out
of his game
he's slowed down it's not only duda is
rising in strength duda is feeling
himself
and playing with flow you've got to
break that flow and you've got to play
fast maybe you change up openings for a
couple of
games i don't think it's a real
necessarily an opening problem as dude
has shifted up himself
but he's got to get back in flow
speeches is not about opening theory
it's about
flow and you can feel the energy out of
fabi right now
i think he thought he was going to roll
in this match when he was up 4-1
it's on it's on he's in trouble it most
certainly is and well
the player is going to take a break we
will do the same and for those of you
who are subscribed to the chess channel
enjoy this primetime smackdown i'm not
even sure who's playing
but it is definitely going to be a good
one so we'll be back in a few for more
action from the speeches championship
[Music]
hey man you ready i have never been
readier for anything in my life robert
okay
you do sound really excited and it's
making me into a little concern
i am excited it does not capture the
extent of my
emotions at the possibility of kicking
grandmaster hess's butt
oh that's what i live for all right well
when i get at least one
upset victory don't cry okay just just
just so we're on the same thing you're
talking about hypotheticals here
i don't like hypotheticals i like
reality and let's see what the reality
has in store for us
well let's see if any of my studies of
your bullet games will help out darn i
thought you were
i thought you would do something random
you know make a bad free move i think
i'm going to play it alpha zero style
my position is already terrible okay we
we know that we know that we all get
you no i mean you're a good player i'm
i'm i'm not going to
deny the facts here wow
oh i forgot you could your bishop or
queen could go back to b2
okay yeah i can go back to d2 well my
queen can go other places other than
those two stars true true i i invite you
to castle short oh queen d7 okay
you you told me i told you and you did
it okay that's that's the kind of
relationship i like
i mean you know we're we're buddies i
just try to be
we are yeah i think my position is not
bad let me get i don't i think my
position is pretty darn good
do you uh well we both clearly robert we
have a disagreement here we both think
our
but dr san credit likes this position
too well that was a nice move and
it was it oh thank you did you seven
my gosh leave me alone
that ain't the only square that's
hanging everything's a problem all right
and i'm gonna take this one too that's
what they're gonna do in north carolina
all right all right all right i got this
you missed that you got this
i know this is all falling into my
plants yes
i this is all of this i'm gonna be
honest with you this doesn't we're gonna
take this
or feel very good for me now we're going
to okay let's not miss checkmate though
let's go here
here um okay
now let's oh queen h2 mate devil oh my
god
i missed him no i'm gonna miss that i
thought you might honestly
oh my i almost did i i did not play e5
to prevent that threat i'll be honest
with you
yes you did come on don't make me feel
good it's like oh my god
oh you want to do this oh crap oh you
just fell for it let's go
all right let's go down here let's go
here oh wait how
oh rook h5 i thought i'd just get you on
top
oh okay i got i did cut that a little
bit too close i will admit
i feel like i almost had you there that
was a nice trap in the end i have yeah
you're caught off guard okay okay
[Music]
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time but this is
the magnus carlson squeeze
um wow and knowing you don't get many
winning positions against magnus carlson
nobody does nicara's playing in front of
hundreds of people
imagine being in his shoes right now
wow unbelievable up by four games well i
can resign yeah
carl knows it it started with 16 players
and uh it all came down
to one man magnus carlson who won
[Music]
this is a pretty great match i know
people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's
a beast
an absolute monster it has been hikaru's
speeches championship this 2018
in car nakamura the overall 1c takes it
home in the species championship
honestly these guys have played each
other so much obviously this is a
rematch of last year's scc final what a
finish by the way i mean that's been the
story of the match
nakamura has just kind of out swindled
out tricked and out calculated wesley in
the critical moment
dude that's a nice move wesley's shaking
his head
ikaro wins the pawn he's gonna draw this
game i can't believe it
that happened unbelievable karo nakamura
holding that position
[Music]
and as we return we want to remind
everybody to get involved with guess
the move no surprises here i am dragon
b70 is the top guesser for the
game uh one of the games we just saw and
get involved because the top three
premium guesters will win
cash prizes and if you're not a premium
member you will win premium membership
so that's a good deal for you
and well speaking of guessing things
correctly
oh gosh it pains me to say this but
smarter chess
was correct five to four and i think
maurice
that fabi just wanted to help smart
chess out he knows it's a tough
environment out there
um you know finding a new job won't be
so easy so he
went from a 4-1 lead into a 5-4 deficit
well you know pollsters have been having
a tough time
lately as you know but smarter chess
seems to be the one they need to go to
like if you want to find out about chess
and maybe
presidential elections whoever's running
smarter chess might be
the man because right now that was a
precise guess
5-4 was indeed the final result and came
in
under the wire because student needed to
have yet another game and there were
only seconds it seemed like left
for them to start that ninth game and
make it possible to go 5-4
fabi's got to be devastated right now
and i see the next prediction to be 5-5
i don't know you lose four in a row
sometimes it's not the score it's how
you
get to that score and he got to this
score by losing
four in a row he was a 4-1
come on you lose four after being on 4-1
the momentum might have shifted already
will fabi
find the energy to come back and make
this match
as competitive at least at this phase as
we think may be the case
well we are about to get the games going
and fabi in the three minute plus one
second
increment time show we just saw five
five is the estimate
and at this point i think that jkd does
have the momentum
and we're getting another one of these
sicilians where fabiano has had some
good positions
but duda was very sharp he was alert
when his back was against the wall in
that previous game
and maurice once again we're in this
line
well duda is making the move h4 look
ridiculous
i mean every position we've seen so far
he's just making h4 that's supposed to
be the super fancy move
he's making it look completely
ridiculous it's like yeah
i'm getting a good position every time
you can play four if you want to but i
know exactly how to equalize and now we
see this line up here on the
on the board and duda has more time than
he started with he's still in his
preparation
in the world did we just see like knight
is pinned knight takes e4 okay i
you take my queen i take yours queen e3
knight takes so he gets it off the door
knight takes d5
saying i don't want my piece back this
is pin there's a discovery here there's
a rook on d1 in your queen
so this is all some kind of theory that
duda knows really well
because he's up on time but this is a
problem maurice
right where both players they know the
first stages it's
who is going to be able to output the
other from this point because it's not
game over it says zeros
but you have to prove that it's not just
a quick draw
well the problem is the liquidation
factor has
come very quickly and now you're right
it is not going to be just an easy draw
from this position black has to stop and
think bishop c4 was a nice move
just add a little bit of extra tension
to the position remember when that
bishop got
stuck on f1 in that nasty game where it
never moved
now the bishop is in the game white has
clean development and the h-file
so if you want to castle queenside
you're gonna have to think about castle
kingside excuse me the other thing about
the fact that that h file is open
so b5 trying to force the action and i'm
seeing this
bar go completely nuts
on this last move it's got to be a
knight e7 move though or is it a knight
six moves look at knight f6 yeah it
takes an e7
probably even better according to this
keeps the advantage
and what does when they come back to f5
this bishop's pin otherwise i could just
take you well what's wrong with is queen
takes
is it just going to be a straightforward
capture capture though
that doesn't seem oh maybe you just need
to pick off oh
you can't oh it's night it's knight d4
at the end
take and play knight d4 you can't castle
well those are good there's queen e4
here too maurice hitting you in uh
all directions oh that's nasty
i mean something has to be winning here
but doesn't 94
no queen e4 looks really good he can be
one
for real and it says stills is plus 4.7
well you can't castle you can't cast it
because the queen to d3
oh that's some g3 is nasty so you just
you can't castle so he's playing a move
where he just put his king away and he
said
okay your turn if you can't castle the
most natural move on the board isn't
possible
it's unlikely you have a move here your
position's
just too terrible and there's no bishop
f4 checks because
putting the king on the light square
over here means that if you do castle
and the queen comes to d3 there's no
sudden checks on the king so king b1
is that calm move and that's where the
evaluation mark can be tricky because
you and i are looking for the direct
knockout and five says
hey i'm comp cool and collected i may
have lost four games in a row but i know
how to play some mean chess
and i mean i don't think our euro queen
e4 was bad
i don't think knight d4 was bad i think
king b1 is great i think white's just
crushing
this position as long as you cannot
castle this is trouble now queen e4 does
allow
and he's playing look at this way off
center move
knight to a5
what a strange move it was threatening
very concretely
this knight move maybe he needs to play
i mean he's gonna play knight b7
knight b7 maybe queen e4 and then knight
b7 right
how can black move here just
feel like i'm trying to figure out i'm
trying to figure out the problem is
having so many wins and white's clock
starts to tick
it seems like it seems to me that you
play queenie for your move
and wait or queen b i mean there's too
many options there's so many options but
that's why i say you make the practical
one
you play queen e4 he cannot castle rook
h7
is a threat right now you cannot play
queen takes g5
so there's a threat on your pawn you
can't take on g5 because your bishop is
hanging
knight c6 or knight b7 is coming there's
got to be a boss move
it's got to be a boss move look how many
threats it's a centralized queen
and there's nowhere like what whatever
you
move there's a move for knight c6 is
coming
there's just too many moves right and
queen c7 can't do that because e6 falls
with check
it just feels like the queen guards c2
by the way
on top of it there's no move there can
be no move
a chest wouldn't be fair if there was a
move it wouldn't be logical
and now this move e5 creating a second
weakness
another weakness on this square now
isn't h7 hanging
if i just take it that's just one i
don't even want it but
it's possible to take it it's also
possible do what he just did
g6 don't castle because if rook takes h7
and mates are coming around your king uh
actually we can just start with queen d5
check
and then you'll be done so castle says
out you got to play this move
and now ooh stop it look at one
you got four seconds left to defend this
monstrosity of a chest position
he's just traded and now his queen can
penetrate if it wants to
this is over yeah queen b7 looks like it
does the trick i mean where's this rook
going it's under attack the bishop one
d6 is still hanging
queen g4 getting into e6 while attacking
the queen e6
and queenie six is is also lights out as
you said that's
that's done no moves a blast of a win
for fabi
coming back that quickly and just
overwhelming him
that was dominant chess robert that was
dominant
dominant chess and we saw them blitz out
the opening right
three minutes and four seconds after
something like 12 moves
and we see zeros on the eval bar but the
position is so complex with that open h
file the king of the center
i wonder if duda will go back to that
line i mean he must because he's been
playing it this entire
event but fabi saw something right he
did some quick
glossing over his openings and he saw
something that he liked
but but you know what that bishop c4
move it was really well timed
let's let's be honest bishop c4 was
really one time but b5 has to be the
culprit
b5 was the problem you don't have time
to play a move like b5
b5 said go ahead do your worst and boy
did he do his worst
on him like bang in your face so
b5 was a huge blunder in that position
does
duda does duda know what to do about
this the next time he sees it
because it was his preparation it
doesn't matter if you have preparation
sooner or later you're going to see a
position you've never seen before your
opponent's going to play a move
that the engine didn't suggest and
you're going to be on your own
and you have to figure it out and he
doesn't have time
to go to the side and check his engine
or get a second to say
hey dude you should have next time you
see bishop c4 do this
so that's going to be challenging for
him and maurice i
have to say we are not seeing the french
anymore probably know the black pieces
played
a king's pawn opening so e4 e5 and here
we are in the italian game
but the knight went to h7 just to move
ago knight h7 that caught due to by
surprise
he spent 27 seconds to play b4
and after queen of six he had another 34
seconds playing d4 in fact
sacrificing a pawn in a standard manner
because white will likely throw the move
e5
with the king in the center to be very
careful before you upon grabbing the
center
with your king uncastled these joko
pianos with these weird night maneuvers
have been
so weird let me just
use the word again been so weird knight
knight g8 we've seen knight from f6 king
ha knight g8
in a position where you say you can't do
that the laws of chess say that the
the central position will open up and
you'll end up in trouble you can't get
away with maneuvers like that
and concrete computer analysis said
oh yes we can actually we can do it no
problem at all
and so black trying for his play b5
though concrete threat by the way
uh li this a-line might open
in a weird way as well i'm using this
word weird robert what
could i get another adjective please i
mean it's unbelievable
obscure i'm an english school i'm an
english major and i i can't go with
another word
trust me i know you have a very
extensive vocabulary so
you don't need to convince me but not
today well that's because things are
weird things have been weird right it
was four to one then it was five to four
duda
and now it's five five and we're getting
new openings and bishop back to e2 so
i have a lot of experience in the black
side of the italian
and these kind of atypical night
maneuvers now i'm using the new word
uh bringing the knight to h7 to g5 it
makes sense
but white does have the big center so
the knight on a5
not exactly thrilled to be there that's
offside here knights on the rim we don't
often like those
but how do you make progress from
white's point of view i guess that's the
essential question
and finally castles after years of
research
he finds castles as the deep move well
we've got this position as you said how
does white
make real progress you don't
want to open up the line for this bishop
on a7 that bishop sits there and waits
and waits and waits and it one day
wishes hopes
that you will capture so that he can do
some damage on that f2 square
so white says okay i'll make one more
waiting move bishop a3 but now
we got your threat of taking on e5 we'll
move out of the way and what's your move
now queen c2 now this
knight that's on g5 it doesn't really
want to trade for the f3 knight
doesn't really want to solve this
problem it would love to go back to e6
and keep assailing that square d4
and looking at the f4 square okay but he
decided
i was i was wrong so i'd like to go for
this trade
on f3 as a better way to play the
position i'm a little surprised by that
by black but it still looks like he's
fairly equal here the 96 move would have
kept the tension robert
this by black is saying i'm not worried
i think i'm still going to be okay
although right now for me that knight on
a5 is
culprit number one right that's why i'm
looking at c5 here as a way to stop
white from doing the same
and to challenge this bishop immediately
but you're right this knight is stuck
out here
and if i can line my queen up on c3 that
knight could already be a goner so you
have to be very careful right now if
you're fobby
c5 doesn't look great because you
mentioned the bishop hitting the f2 pawn
playing c5 makes your bishop look worse
in addition to your knight being
trapped over here on the rim so and what
i don't like about the situation it's
probably being down to 35 seconds and
ticking
we're still in the opening this is we
just left the opening
like literally just left the opening and
now we've played this move c5
we've buried if you look you said bury
this bishop
and we haven't solved the night problem
the knight still has
years years into the future to wonder
when does when do i get back into the
game guys like what's the deal
you might have to rely on some kind of
bishop f3 rook d4 even if it costs you
an exchange
it's a thematic exchange sack with a
rook d4 movement that's why i put the
bishop on c7
is hey if you take me on d4 my bishop
can open up but for the time being fabi
trying to sit on the position but duda
up
25 seconds nearly it's still tense
because there's no breakthrough just yet
and i'm looking at both sides maurice
rook d1 rook d5 and for black rook to d4
who's plopping a rook down on the d file
first and knight
back i think that black was relieved to
see what just happened
no question about it and now a capture
and b6
and he's at least got a path back to the
b7 square but guess who has a path
to d5 here comes the knight and oh boy
this ain't going to be fun
night on d5 well maneuvered there
and black's pieces look a little silly
the knights not the knight's not facing
any difficulty on
on the a5 square and he looks like he's
going to play the move f6 at some point
to try to shut everything down he needs
to do it quickly knight
back trying to get the knight into the
game make sense
maybe this will come to a3 just trying
to take over the a file and
strategically black is lost
but it might not be so easy to get that
knockout punch and that's
really where the issue will be for uh
jkd and oh down to ten seconds almost
for both here
this is the time scrambles requests
total time scramble and he's taking over
the a file
himself no real threats for white so
black is
hanging in there and i just want to play
f6 i don't know why he wasn't played a
long time ago i just
i just want to play the move f6 but now
bobby understanding that at time
pressure it's all about just making
moves
all about he's making moves and he's
threatened something defense
root back and just make a move just keep
going
it's just can you take on c4 i mean b2
is hanging in many of these variations
so
you're calculating lines robert they
just want to repeat they just want to
repeat
just probably just moving rook rook play
of six already fabi just make the move
and get a solid position stop looking
for reasonable ideas
three seconds four seconds left can they
last robert this is crazy
i know it is the 95 is very strong but
that's all that you have for white right
now the real coming watch out for
doubling on the first rank that would be
devastating looks like they may be
trying to flag each other
i mean bobby doesn't care he's repeating
moves unless he sees a threat and now he
should play f6 he's finally on the board
and he just should repeat
just this is ridiculous neither side
knows what to do exactly so they're just
pushing
things around h5 on the board g6 at some
point probably necessary but you're
right i mean they're just trying to
figure out
how not to lose on time at this point he
just looked like he hung
the but now c4 is actually hanging oh no
two pieces are hanging in this position
but he's playing knight f7
and he's just dropped a piece he just
dropped a piece
bobby dropped the piece and now he's
lost
now he's lost there's the game
unreal oh my gosh and if that's
any indication for what we'll see in
bullet then fob is in huge trouble
because
there is that one second increment which
gives you time to think a little bit to
regain your composure
bobby never was able to do that granted
that judah's position was better from
the very beginning
he had control over the board sorry
robert
put your knight on f7 leave your knight
on f7
play rook a2 rook a4 rookie tour k4
until
the guy threatens it was
totally irresponsible what he just did
what he was did was irresponsible
and in a blitz game no way and here we
have this position again
bobby just blew that game in when you're
down to those last few seconds
and you have a mechanism for making
repetitive moves
that's what you do i remember my my
friend
william morrison they call him the
exterminator i don't know if you've ever
heard of him
robert but he's a new york product
straight out of brooklyn
and he had one trick winning time
pressure
keep your rook close to the clock
wherever the clock is
and keep moving when you have a
situation you can repeat moves
keep repeating moves near the clock
where you could you can hit your clock
and just keep repeating the move short
short moves with the rook
rook a2 rook a1 if you have to and just
be right near that clock and just do it
over and over again
same thing applies in this situation he
had rook a2 rook
a4 there was no reason to deviate from
that and he ended up
losing a piece and the game and now we
see the same line
duda seemingly has done
uh a little bit different in the line
but i'm not sure he's improved his
prospects
dramatically and here's b5 on the board
again
there has to be some kind of issue with
this bishop on d6 hanging i was already
look
they should d wait what this what is
this
legit there may be some kind of bishop
takes b5
check and queen takes d5 is that i think
he's i think he's
lucky if that's happening before
he didn't plan this oh he did not plan
this
he is fortunate that this is on the
board and duda is looking at it like
what are you for real
i feel like this is somewhere in the
fabi files like this you don't
play bishop back to d3 hanging the
knight he could have spent more time
it said he spent seven seconds when
bishop d3 and then went rook to d4
and he's getting his piece back oh watch
out for bishop before though
you might you you better hope you get
your piece back
because there's no r5 just yet and king
b1
there's a bishop h our bishop b3
sighting solving that problem
except the bishop on e5 the bishop on on
d6 is still a problem even on e5 it
could be a problem
i i don't know why did i don't think
this is the favi files robert
i disagree i think fabi is now on skates
and hoping that it works out for him
he can throw in the check he does that
to get make sure that his queen isn't
getting
pinned when the bishop comes to f4 and
this is under attack bishop e6 there's
rook takes d6 because if queen takes
always look if pieces are on the same
line each other move the piece out the
way that's between them
bishop takes b5 check will scoop up the
queen on d6 so there are tactics here
that will regain white the piece and
queen e7 was played rook takes d5 and i
see the eval bar off the side here
saying
white is just cruising that's incredible
what just happened i mean
from oops oops oh wait a minute i'm back
in business
this is amazing the bishop on f4 and the
knight on g3
do not compete against the developed
pieces that white has and black is down
a row
black is currently down a rook on that
square has a lot of problems to solve
we've seen this before
will probably be able to make the breaks
he needs to get the big advantage in
this position and i do feel something
weird about this knight on g3
that bishop this construction this
constellation of forces
is keeping him afloat but something
feels weird and now g6
oh man something really feels strange
here
if you could somehow play a rook d7 and
a bishop c4
and maybe c4 first there's actually rook
d7 and you can't play king g7 what's
wrong with what's wrong with that
i'm just going to show that you can't
play king g7 because you walk into a pin
and lose a piece
rookie 7 looks great rook d7 is
bishop takes on g5 you have to calculate
and he actually
is giving up the g5 pawn because there's
rook to g4
hitting both pieces here so fabi
fighting but if rook b7 right
now right if fabi
probably played rook d7 so now the the
problem is this this is what i was
asking
right what exactly is the point
well he got this way in the best
possible continuation
is this the live position yeah he
brought his rook to d4 to challenge the
mission
my bad so he found this attack well yeah
no it's not your bad i mean it's good to
illustrate rook d7 is the natural move
but that he drops his rook to d4 to
challenge the bishop kick it to a worse
square
and if it takes there is bishop h force
exactly
exactly i'm not i'm not necessarily a
fan of the two pieces here
although it's although that night let me
let me check me switch that
yeah it's good that knight on c5 is a
monster and you just need b4
to cement it and that's done and the a6
pawn
with the b5 pawn and the bishop but
there is a three to one on the other
side so there will be counter play
three to one i'm looking at a4 right now
to scoop off the a6
i think yeah just gotta be aggressive
gotta be aggressive on that side
go go go he's gotta run and now he wants
to take on a six he doesn't want the a4
pawn he wants to take on a6
and then the b-pawn will be a beast
this looks winning yeah two on none on
that side of the board
and oh don't allow rook takes c5 with
your bishop hang that's the one tactic
you do not want to overlook here
uh yeah that's not going to happen no
and here goes the
counter play this is what he wants this
counter play on the other side
an interesting move rook f3 saying will
you play rook f5
you think you're going to be holding
this position down
not going to happen and wow a3
on the other side of the board i think
you can just safely
sit your king on a2 but i guess the
point is if you take on a3
we liquidate and maybe there is some
chance with h3 and rookie three check
no rook g5 is the issue but he's played
bishop f1
to prove that this idea does not work
this idea does not work you sacrifice
your opponent for no reason
and now all white has to do is move the
knight and start pushing him baby
and this is going to be a big problem
yeah though this g2 pawn is a bit of an
issue as well right bishop e4 there's
f5 a very tiny are you worried about the
g2 pawn robert i can play
b5 you really want this pawn i guess
you're right i i'm just making sure my
opponent doesn't queen
but bishop e4 noun
bishop exactly bishop and you have to
spend
years trying to figure out i mean b7 b8
is very
compelling it's very compelling like
that's
that's for real i buy it b7 the knight
d7 just
loves the game lights out even knight a6
wins but 97 gets the job done and
those pawns aren't going anywhere fast
enough they are not
nearly quick enough i used to play a
game with my students
bishop versus three pawns just the
bishop versus the three pawns
in this case we have a knight that's
coming back
there's no chance there's no chance
you're not getting anywhere
as the knight bounces back way too fast
oh and
what did he do what you had to bring the
knight back is he's still okay
all right he's guessed that it's okay
but that means duda made a mistake
because it said zeros for a hot second
there i there was i don't know maybe the
the engine was just a little too
exuberant in that moment but now look at
this
beautiful formation of knight and bishop
shutting things down harmony
scary position for a second there was it
true that it was a draw
yeah we'll bring this up on the analysis
board as the next game gets started but
also
i think that duda needs to stop playing
this sharp sicilian because fabiano
has the better preparation that we've
been seeing in the last couple games
we've been seeing
it we've been seeing it but let's see so
f4 must have been the move here
just try to play f3 and get this pawn
going
boy he should have brought his i think
he should have brought his bishop
but you know what i'm not even sure what
the right move is instead of c4
now that you look at it
i don't know so see because you can't
this is exactly the game you play once
the pieces get to where they would get
to maybe knight
d4 but knight d4 allows king e5
so bishop h1 f4 anyway knight back
not really sure what the move should
have been that's going to bother me for
a while until i figure out
yeah i guess the uh you know there was
something there we'll maybe try to take
a look at it later but
dudeo with two seconds on his clock
wasn't going to be able to play
perfectly nor was fabiano who
had the advantage and let it slip for
just a single move there
but maurice six six fabiano so far
in the three plus one he has two wins to
one and we should mention
there have been precisely zero draws in
this match
incredible no great point robert
incredible 12 games 12 decisive
games on that and by the way white won
that game so the string of
black victories has been righted
somewhat as we've seen white win some
games now
wow what a match this is awesome stuff
this is awesome stuff and you know it's
dead even
smarter chess had had duda with a
a game edge after this portion he's
still on his way that possibly could do
that
but saying he's going to dominate in the
bullet
and this is going to be dangerous for
fabi because if that's true
bobby needs some lead right now
like now he needs to start picking him
up and putting them down
right now get some wins but they've
traded punches in the last three games
haven't they
they have indeed and i feel like fabi
feels that pressure because look at the
openings he's choose
he went away from the french it wasn't
working for him now he's going to the
black side of these italian games
and he's going for the more aggressive
lines of the pawn on g5
and that's a double-edged sword on one
hand those pawns can help you launch and
attack maybe a g4 or king to g7
and f5 type of pushes on the other hand
you're creating
weak squares in front of your king and
that can really backfire and that's why
duda strikes in the center
so quickly here so funny though
because black had won so many games and
then white's just won three in a row
yeah in fact
might have even won four in a row four
yeah the last game of the um
the five minute was one minute it was
also a win so white has one point in a
row we're like look at black black is
rolling
and now white is like bing bing and by
the way
this has also come after they changed up
a little bit in the opening
so fabi changing from the french
this last game has not helped him no
in in in this game as well he's down
quite a bit of time here
right 30 seconds and it's kings on g7
there's some openness to it
but i'm not buying the evaluation right
now so
sometimes maurice we look at it as grand
masters like okay that makes perfect
sense
here it's still such a clogged messy
position
and i see some potential for black
eventually playing with the h5
and h4 with an attack on the king side
so
i do believe that white is probably
slightly better especially now that i'm
looking at knight c4 ideas
but perhaps there are some potential for
black but now that i'm looking at knight
c4 i'm
actually just loving white's chances and
robert i'm going to say this too
i'm not seeing flow from fabi let's
check the time in this position
four seconds five seconds six seconds
seven seconds it's a three minute game
you just went into a deep think
it's ten seconds have passed you're
still thinking you saw duda just made
his move in about four seconds
he's still it he's still at it it's
still going it's a three minute game
you don't have 20 plus seconds to think
on each move i'm not
feeling that flow and he's still at it
come on dude you're now under a minute
and in crisis
already this is not what you should be
doing in this kind of time
situation it's just this time control
does that punishes you
it punishes you for spending this kind
of time and soon he's going to start
making mistakes i don't care what movie
comes up with
i don't think it better be a genius move
it better be winning by force
because f6 after all that thought that's
not the kind
i mean that's not it that's not the move
where you thought you should be spending
all that
clock burning all that clock for this is
my problem and now night back looking at
those weak
juicy like squares
not feeling what he did and look how
quickly he played 93 a practical move
quickly and again how many seconds have
passed
before finally dropping his bishop too
many but maurice i think this is going
to show that
what i considered a double edged
position is not really so double edged
after all
clearly duda has the advantage here and
white's pieces
are superbly placed control over the
light squares as you're mentioning
the king on g7 not looking so happy so
maybe i was looking
for hope because i play the black side
of the italian and not so much the white
side but this is
not very pretty this is ugly this is
absolutely
ugly and here's the deal when you trade
off the dark square bishops when you are
playing a chess game
and you trade off your dark square
bishops that means you have an extra
piece that can control the light square
that your opponent doesn't have in this
case black has a bishop on b6
congratulations but white has the bishop
on b3 and the two knights
those pieces can control light squares
so you want to dominate the light
squares and you see there that maneuver
bring the knight to f1 to put upon on g4
put a knight on g3
and if your opponent can't crush you on
the dark squares you're killing them
i mean you're just killing them so this
is what dude is looking for is
ultra domination on the light squares
where you can get rid of two pieces but
you're still gonna be left with a
problem
when your opponent smashes you on
the light squares and here we see just a
simple play by duda
although i will say maurice it's the
second time we've seen duda play over
there on the queen side when we've liked
his potential to king side there was
that french game
uh as well so opening the b file it's
not bad
for white but it does give black some
hope some prospects
to open the position up and say hey my
king side is already weak at least now
i'll get some counter play on the other
side of the board
yes and all the time by the way black
has been
hoping to be able to take on d4 and
capture the pawn on e4
but he has to calculate it on every
single move and by the way we've been
talking all this time
and dude has spent a lot of time on the
clock going down only 29 seconds
but there goes the knight we talked
about the light squared dominant piece
and that knight's going to end up on g3
there's nothing to do about it the
bishop on v6
cannot come into the party so now
white is dominating black is
desperate h5 please give me a little bit
of release
so that i can go and guard the f5 square
he's ditched the pawn duda has won
a straight pawn this is going downhill
fast
it certainly is because it's just an
extra pawn clean
the light squares are still a problem oh
king on h6
queen g4 or rook h3 coming i was trying
to bring the queen h3 but the rook is
better
the king stuck and he wins it's over
that was all about the light squares
that was all about the light squares in
that position
and the clock times bobby spent so much
time trying to think about the position
that he just ended up losing easily and
judah now has left the sicilian
as you mentioned yes oh yes excuse me
yeah
sorry robert yes
as you mentioned this the sicilian was
not working for him you guessed right
he said get out of there and he's out
and he's now playing petrol
i'm gonna have to start calling you
danny i guess but he has gone to the
petrov
which i believe is especially a
dangerous choice
because the world's leading expert in
the petrol that would be
one fabiano caruana so dude himself is
quite
a promising petrol player he's an expert
in it
but bobby is the boss in the petrov
it is true it is true indeed he
is and
is that the fifth game in a row that
white won
it is yeah i mean white is making black
look completely silly at the moment
like just crushing and this move c4
hyper committal move blocking your own
bishops diagonal
weakening the d4 square giving a target
on d6 square
i mean you you see a move like this
under classical chess principles and you
think
what are you doing like are you mad but
the key is that he's after squares he's
after specific squares
he's after some control he's saying that
it's not going to be easy
for white to take advantage of anything
especially the move d5 happens
and he's going to aim for his own play
with queen side storm
so white needs to prove something here i
don't think it's easy
at all especially d5 threatens bishop
takes on a three
eventually it's going to be a queen a5
and bishop a3 siding with a knight takes
c3
tactic amazing anti-principled move
and by the way 92 right now might get
hit in the face by knight c3
[Music]
it's like bing bing bing wake up and
smell the coffee
uh in a position like this you're gonna
get murdered with the attack coming
straight at you
so very dynamic
interesting idea giving up the weak
square on d4
so that you can get this dynamic
possibility for black and i think black
has
real chances here to get b5 and a5 in uh
or even even queen a5 bishop a3 looks
possible what's up with that
i guess you do have knight d2 now
because you put the bishop on d4 so
if we just go through this move by move
we'll analyze a second so we play b5 but
queen a5
knight d2 bishop a3 i'm not going to
react by taking on a3 i'll take on e4
first which also frees up the d2 square
and then i can take on
a3 next because i've stolen your snd but
b5 is the other thematic idea we were
mentioning
and it's on the board and he's headed
places
he's headed places with this move with
his whole plan it's not just the move
itself
it's the whole plan white's attack looks
ridiculously slow
like what is where's the target how does
white hit
black how you don't g3
yeah that's he's not going for an attack
i guess he's trying to play bishop g2 at
some point and go after d5
and what's going on here maurice and
what we're trying to
elaborate for people is that black has
the immediate positions like that kind
of
energy that you have to use now or else
white is going
to be better the potential the position
seems to favor white this knight can go
to f1 to e3 if the queens if you just
threw them off the board
all of a sudden we'd like white's
position but with the idea of a5 b4
that's what is allowing black to claim a
good position
indeed and the only weakness is the d5
pawn but it's not under
any siege as yet knight f5 i
he must not have liked going after a5
maybe because of bishop c5 maybe that
was what
was tickling his brain that stopped him
from doing it so now he's played knight
f5 and now
we said a5 is coming a5 b4 in chess you
need brakes
you need brakes and that's the break
that's the money break b4 so it's not
hard to figure out the kind of plan that
black was after
and that was it getting that b4 move in
he might even be able to play right now
but he has to calculate
knight to c6 does he want to
give that move that's a big move to give
and he's decided nope i'm not giving it
yet
i'm going to play this one he also has
to calculate any trickery like knight
takes on f7
nonsense you got to look at but
thankfully bishop takes is ready and
nothing happens there
either so what is fabi going to do now
because he has no play he's
just bereft of any moves like devoid of
possibilities here
b4 is coming his king is about to be at
pride open
i'm sorry but this looks like eight six
about to happen for duda oh this looks
great for him he's showing a great
understanding of hey
my attack is coming first let's not
trade pieces because my opponent's
gasping for air
the knight on e5 that looks good but
it's not actually threatening anything
and b4 is what's all about fobby dipping
to 30 seconds and below due to still
over men in the clock
another fantastic showing here for the
polish number one amazing and queen h
who h a what h.o.y
like what are we doing that that's was
there a reason to give him
a free tempe and now he's dropped back
but the a4 pawn
looks man it looks juicy if we could get
at it
but that knight is guarding the the
chicken house right now
how do you get at this this guy because
you got to break through on that side
you don't you played rook b8 by the way
even if he didn't know exactly how to do
it root beat is a smart move
right they're one of the greatest moves
you can have in chess greatest ideas
robert you know this kind of trickery
make a move that threatens nothing it
just builds your position
yeah you can play b3 at some point it
does actually have a clear purpose let's
barrel down the b
file right yeah it's overall purpose but
not necessarily a concrete one it's just
an improving move and it says i'm not
throwing anything concrete it's on you
to find a move
and your opponent has to look now see
he took what whoa yeah he's getting all
active here but rook takes d4 comes to
my mind and watch out for this black
king getting in trouble with knight g4
at some point
he got a little concrete there and i was
i was lauding the fact
that he was not being concrete and then
he got concrete
and this this could give some chances
knight g4 is not possible though knight
c6 queen protects c3 importantly and
then tries to get the diagonal
man i want my knight over there on the
darkness
the clock duda down to only eight
seconds and now he's in trouble
on the clock this last move the knight
looks like it doesn't
and he's taken c4 he wanted to take us
before the bishop was pinned there
but are you for real three
oh no oh wow this is crazy talk
and knight c4 and that's going to trade
everything off if he takes on c4
and takes again and plays oh because
bishop d5 rook d8
saves the day he's trading everything
off but white has enough material
yeah white certainly does i could play
bishop d5 then
push or bring the king up and
white is perfectly fine yeah white
should be okay here
black the preferred side because the
past pawns like going anywhere
that's the thing you have a bishop black
can just block hate in the dark squares
very easily
and unfortunately the rook by itself is
not going to be able to win the pawns
but time
time is what's important is the whole
thing right now is they're both down
can they manage this position white is
fine but can he win
is there a chance and this last move by
just got to be careful
okay the position and giving white the
chance to play f3 king e4
when he's gonna play it he's gonna put
his king on f5 this is winning
this got oh why did he play kg6 this
looks winning but actually i don't see
how to make any progress
that's the first or anything there's no
way to make progress there's nobody who
can break the dark squares
this is going to be a draw yeah it's
like you need black to have to lose a
move somehow but there's always rook c8
rook c7 no
that was the key move he tried to trick
him king d6 so that he could play king
c5 robert you saw that sneaky action
bobby tried to do
he tried to get the king over to d4
square now he's guarded c5
now here comes the king king's gonna
come around he's gonna challenge him to
know exactly what to do i think king d8
is going to solve the problem though
here he comes again and i was another
don't play at five don't blinking at
five is rookie five check so he goes
back to d4
nah this is just drawing right now
they're still going
one second increments is keeping fabi
alive but now he definitely cannot make
progress this is completely done
completely done no way to make any
progress anyway
the only person who can make progress is
black honestly if uh you know you can
attack the bishop and either win the c6
or g4 pawn
that could spell some trouble but fabio
you know what i agree with you if i were
black i played rookie one is there a
danger to playing rookie one
no like zero danger to playing rookie
one right absolutely no now bishop f5
bishop d7 was the easiest way to hold
but this also does the trick
so okay the first draw that was the
first draw yeah
we've seen a draw finally are we sure
we're watching super grandmasters play
and look petrol for fabi he says
hey you thought you were knew what you
were doing my turn
they avoided the petrol this whole time
and the pressure off has that
reputation sometimes of being just a
solid opening for
black but it's been sharp over the years
fabian's infused some life into it for
sure
but wow this has been an amazing match
it's so close
i mean it's so close bobby took the
sprint took the lead
duda sprinted back took his lead bobby's
still punching
and now it's a one point match this is
what you want to see
close dynamic and by the way
very few blunders that's true we're
playing
blitz and it's very few blunders is this
what we
expect to see throughout the rest of
these matches
what an amazing entertaining
set of games we're in for instead of
matches we're going to be in for
as the speedchest championships continue
certainly the case and right now
duda's spending a ridiculous amount of
time trying to figure this position out
i guess he's looking can i push this
pawn to d5 and free up the d4 square for
my knight
is there something going on the e file
with my rook already attacking the
knight and
uh having a good scope here but he's
spending so much time and i don't think
you can afford to do that
in a three-minute game i completely
agree and then you end up playing the
move knight c3 after all that thought
and what's curious is bobby probably
would have played instantly if 93 were
on the board and now fabi's thinking
i find that fascinating sometimes
players get into each other's rhythms
like one person does something the other
copies and here fabi
with only 17 seconds having elapsed he
needs to find
the next move quickly and he's played
his knight
to the b4 square what an interesting
i'm not gonna say i'm a fan of this move
i think you and i both have the same
reaction like that looks interesting but
it's always a bad adjective because
well he does bring the knight to d3 and
he can take on c1 but
that bishop wasn't really helping queen
take c1
i'm i'm surprised by i'm surprised by a3
i thought he would have played bishop e3
yeah and that way knight d3 had no punch
that's what i thought
but all right they went for something
different
and again it's all about the clock fobby
with a 42nd lead
and thereabouts two bishops as well an
isolated pawn
on d4 white is going to fight for
activity
the fight is the hardest maybe he might
even play d5
if given a chance so white has maximum
activity for the isolated pawn
while black has a solid structure e5
seems like the only break robert
yeah i agree and this knight on d6 is
the real hero because the f7 square
is what white wants a target with this
bishop on b3 but the knight covers it
and 95 looks to increase the pressure
please take me on e5 so i can take with
my pawn no longer an isolated pawn and
now an attacker but of course
black will not be capturing there and if
you play d5 i'll push through to c5
my bishop on f6 will be happier and i'll
try to use a queen side majority and
knight
is the best blockader against and i was
going to say
this after saying all that this calls
for a judith polgar
g4 and judah did this when she was maybe
16 or 17 years old is the first time i
saw this idea
g4 in the isilani position and
man when i saw it it came as a shock
back in the day
g4 now is kind of like those yeah
everybody plays g
for it but robert when you were gay high
when you were first coming up to me as a
was it a nine-year-old
yeah the first time we met that's when
those kind of
moves were considered crazy you can't
play g4 in this kind of position
but they started doing all kinds of g4
in every position
and here we see it was something
standard for duda but he spent so much
time doing it he's only got 45 seconds
left on the clock
and just like our first interaction you
know when you play g4
you're signing those autographs because
that's a dazzling move
often but here where's the follow-up you
know it's like
i got g foreign the bishop just sat back
on g6 is
hanging out there you're speaking
quickly bobby responded with g5
yeah because he's a boss himself that's
the important point
g4 was met by g5
like that's the kind of double double
double take in the bishop on g6 the pawn
on g5 holding the position together
very nicely those dark squares not going
anywhere no h4
threat no f4 threat that black has to
worry about the clock maurice i wasn't
even looking at that but
look how much time fabi has and he's in
his petrov even though it's a sharp
ver what just taking bishop take him
oh wait you can't play bishop there's
something wrong
i see h6 as a move oh what a calm move
threatening bishop g5
okay okay it's funny i was like
i know bishop g5 was in your head
because you saw you saw the uh
by the way no it was
no it didn't work but i saw the eval bar
go crazy so i was like oh bishop g5 wins
material but of course the rooks and the
was in the path the vision base bottom
line is duda has 6.4 seconds
left to play the rest of this game now
it's time for fabi to find a couple of
nice little trickery type moves and the
game will be over there is a blunder
waiting
and you just need to find the right
couple of moves now spend 15 seconds
duda is suffering at the board right now
he's suffering
he he doesn't he just wants you to move
it look at this last move
this is the kind of move i'm talking
about it does nothing
i mean it really does nothing there's no
threat
right but suddenly duda has to be like
uh what
wait what oh and there goes the knight
he's going to and
and he's got to find a move now bobby
needs to find an incisive move
that scares his opponent bishop g5
not sure that was it the queen now
backing up to f2
the f7 pawn is under heavy pressure and
h4 also is a threat because
the queen doesn't actually have access
to the diagonal agreed
i don't know fabi's last couple of moves
did not help him he's turned
the game seems to have turned around
queen queen to d6
allowing h4 bishop back and h5
and boy there is serious pressure coming
down the f-file right now and it looks
like
there may be a sacrifice bishop 87 what
are you thinking about
yeah i don't know what he's taking time
for take on f7 this is what he was
worried about a sacrifice
on this square is the knight but this
looks
this what's going on could you straight
queens could have taken on f2 if you
want it but this
okay still hanging in here okay this is
this is great for black that he got out
of it
with this kind of no damage at all again
the seconds two seconds left
for duda and fabi just needs to find
some simple simple moves this last one
i'm not a fan of the she's going in the
opposite corner
he won rookie two no but rook f2 uh
we're gonna say
but you trade rooks and probably are
better than the same king f6 the g5
coming
yeah this is good for black knight
dominantly good for black
knight is better here but it's not over
it's not over it's bad but it's not
completely over and now the knight
headed to the e5 square
and king g5 should be played right not
to oh okay
and now you can't guard everybody and
pawn's gonna drop
pawns are gonna drop like flies now
fabi's gonna win this one
and the match is gonna be tied
incredible
extraordinary and it's the domination of
a knight against a bishop we hear the
bishop pair how strong it is
pieces that can go on both sides of the
board but a knight can go from color to
color and a bishop has to stay on its
own so here
careful robert be careful oh i'm not i'm
not liking this technique
no i'm not liking this technique okay
just that doesn't matter he's got it
that's not gonna matter if he can trade
off the light square bishop
it's a draw fabian's it
oh my god he has blown it this is a
drawing position no i don't know the
king is pretty far away so if black can
shoulder that king out can't you try to
i guess you're not in time this is a
technical draw it's just a question of
whether he'll blunder it
but this is a technical draw uh as you
cannot
you can't block you got to block
properly you've got to block more than
once
and right now he's trying to shoulder
him so at some point the problem is your
king has to come back to be able to
bring the knight
to the g4 square and here we go
he's going to bring his king back had to
and now just bring your pieces over take
it
and that's a draw bobby blew it look at
him shaking his head
blew a winning position that is
a huge miss a huge miss for fabi not
winning that game
you know what we've learned maurice is
the petrov is always a draw
[Laughter]
indeed they had no draws until the two
petrov games
and both of those games had at first it
looked good for black
with fobby there then all of a sudden
due to turn the tables but he had no
time
to figure everything out yeah that was
terrible for fabi that not not winning
that game that was really bad
that was really bad and he was disgusted
at himself because that's a huge point
that he tossed away and they're down to
what looks like the last
two games of the three-minute action
we're only
unless there's a horrific blunder early
and we have not seen that in this match
i think we've seen it once i think there
was one bad game
where fabi had that horrible white
sicilian
remember that game yes and and there was
that other game where judo was black and
that's sicilian when he went b5 and just
i mean it can end that quickly but
you're right you're right good point so
there were two sicilians
where they blunted but otherwise this
has been a quality match this has been a
dog fight these two players and just a
small
edge for duda at the moment bobby really
wanted to be at
could have been it seven and a half
seven and a half after that last game
should have been
now he's gonna have to do it all over
again and i have to give a shout out to
our
top guesters from the last game because
i see an international master feeding
master
two more ims and a gm all playing guess
the move trying to win
either the cash prize or if you're not a
premium member win some premium
membership so great to see that
and maurice i mean speaking of great to
see i feel like fabi
from the white side of this position the
two bishops are stronger
than we've seen in the past and look at
the light squares that's going to tell
the tale of this game
is this light square bishop and good
control
over the vacated squares that black has
created
i hear you robert i am trying to figure
out
how exactly though white makes the
pressure work
on the light squares i you need to help
me out here because
i just don't see although that last move
right
not a fan the threat is night it was
knight takes f4 and queen takes
i'm just curious how white oh if white
gets the if y gets the d5 by the way
right i'm just trying that was the oh it
didn't even work
that's funny it didn't even work yet but
that was the plan
right right it didn't quite quite work
it
if this bishop gets to this bishop gets
to
d5 then we're talking
right queen e4 what a move
what's a move interesting interesting
and strange to be honest because
you're after queen d7 you get nothing on
the next move
you do get nothing you're gonna
move your queen now because now black is
threatening bishop g5
he didn't move isn't there a bishop g5
bishop e3
siding somewhere uh yes
i like that bishop as much as i'd like
your bishop on d5 i mean
i guess the bishop on d5 actually puts
pressure on well no bishop to d5 anymore
but pawn's there
i don't get it if i put a bishop if i
put a
bishop on e3
why didn't he put his bishop on you're
asking questions that i
honestly don't have the answer to
because bishop to e3 looked correct
just imagine this position same position
with the bishop on e3
saying no progress for you what the heck
why wouldn't you just put it there i
don't get
it he's gonna make a draw anyway right
now no but bishop on e3
i'm playing the position this i'm making
a draw right
this is just a draw now this is nothing
in the petrol
well we said they might be two more
games
only but with this kind of position
quick draw they might be
two more games after this as they've
drawn it's true unless this is a very
long game we will get
two more and just remind everybody of
how young christoph duda
even made his way to the speeches
championship he won the invitational he
beat
sergey karjakin in fact it was quite a
lopsided affair
and before karjakin he beat jeffrey
zhang and also
the wonderful time international master
min lay so a very strong performance on
him he said
i'm going to make it to the speedus
championship here he is right now he is
the white side of this position
he is up eight and a half seven f
against fabiano and maurice
we're getting down towards the wire so
in the home stretch here we know duda
is the favorite on paper and the bullet
does fabi have a chance or must he
strike right now
in the final blitz games well he's got
to be even i think he doesn't want to be
down and then i have to win in the
bullet that
doesn't sound right it doesn't sound
logical it sounds like he'll be crushed
but he does have his chances and he's
been playing well
no i'm not sure about his bullets b
we'll see that
by the way we talked about seeing our
first draw are we seeing our first
d4 opening of communities
but they've played e4 in in every single
game we saw
16 games go by and one e4
was the move of choice there was no c4
there was no knight f3
and there was no this d4 that we have
now seen for the first time as duda said
it's time to get away from that boring
petrov i could be bored in
something else why be bored in the po
fabi's
super duper petrov it's kind of
interesting because bobby played the
french he won three games in the french
before he had to get out of it after
losing a couple
and now he's headed to the petrov and he
hasn't lost any games has he no he did
lose in the petrol
no he should have did he lose the game
or he
no he should have lost no he should have
liquidated yeah right so so now
we're talking uh duda said enough
probably he's good in the
that's enough let's get somewhere else
and see what happens
but this one point lead is big for for
duda i think that's going to really
matter
and uh this position is this is what we
call a gm grind
where white says i have no losing
chances it's basically two results
and black says i don't believe my one
single weakness on d5 is enough
this should be draw with correct play
especially
in classical but we're not playing
classical will black be able to make all
the precise moves or does fabi
understand these positions
enough in his fingertips robert that
he's going to draw easily
you know maurice this is one of those
openings that i do not recommend for
quicker time controls because
black has isolated pawn you know you're
tied down to the defense of that forever
and you're not actually targeting
anything of whites look at this queen on
d4 it's a marvelous piece
keeping the rook on a8 stuck to the pawn
a7
putting pressure on the d5 square
protecting b2 for good measure
so i just think it's very difficult for
father to play and you're right that if
this were a classical game fabi's so
strong
i wouldn't be too worried about his
chances i don't know something about it
just feels
so easy for white to play and not so
easy for black to deal with
sure it is sure it is very easy for
white to play and now white offers
an end game which black will probably
accept and he has
done so these are just the types that
gm's
at this level as you mentioned there's
no counter play for black
but gm's at this level feel like there's
only one weakness
the right pieces get traded off i have
no worries
maybe i'll move like f6 and put the
bishop back on e6
it's just just i mean of course this
knight is headed to d4
so you'll see the knight probably
repurpose itself
e5 is not a real square for this piece
rook c8 is inviting more draws
as well so you have to be very careful
there
uh it's just just a droid type
position rook c7
on the board and look at this giving
giving the pawn
on b7 because of mass liquidation
do you buy this there might be some back
rank tactics with knight c5 coming
that's what i'm worried about for
white because uh if i could take on
first i'll kick your knight from e5 with
an f6
in timely fashion and i'll take your
bishop on d3 and your rook will be
overloaded
defending the bishop and the first rank
i know that may be hard to visualize
that's slick i'm gonna say that's real
slick
uh like this right i get uh but is it
true
it's slick but is it true i just want to
know because this is the
you know the knight g6 you get a check i
go away you take i take it they can take
and you say
my two pawns versus your two pieces
well well well very fancy very fancy
just to remind everybody the back rank
is what we're focused on so the rook
can't take the night
but as we get back to the game rook c1
was played 96 and maurice
now i'm definitely going to say you are
right the pieces are coming off
white is still a smidgen better but
that's
all that it is and i've seen uh this is
not enough
no it's not i've seen players um you
know
just win these games from the white side
arena crush is one player
who is excels at these types of
positions i remember from
the 2018 olympiad against henrikh
dramale she
gave her the iceland a pawn and then
just squeezed her
but this is not it once the pieces come
off mass
simplification this should be a hole you
want a pair of rooks
you just want a pair of rooks now the
only good news uh for fabi the real good
news
other than the draw i should say it's
more than just a little bit of news
is that he's got a lot of time advantage
on the clock duda couldn't find anything
in a position where he would be slightly
better
and fabio at the moment has a small time
edge he's going to just keep playing
g5 you know you start weakening make
some weakening moves
white is gonna think about beating you
here comes the king
first all right let's get the bishop out
of there i think that king is gonna
start marching here he goes
it can go beyond b4 though folks this is
the problem because when you play king
b4
b6 will be playable but be ready because
knight c6 will be did he just play
knight b5
he did well that's the end of that we
don't have to talk about this game
anymore
we trade knights off uh that's it that's
all she wrote
king king d6 although how do you protect
this pawn because if i go bishop b3 and
you go bishop here i have e4
with a pin pawn that's a point
that's a point uh hmm maybe it's like
bishop f5 to e6 or something like that
so that way the king protects it but
still it's like
it's crazy i mean you can play bishop f7
in bishop right same idea
yeah okay oh h3 is his idea open the g4
he just blundered oh he blows him g4 he
just blundered
he just blended a position he should
have stayed solid he just blundered in
seven seconds for duda
and fabi realizes that he just
absolutely
blunder the position unbelievable
unbelievable he just blundered and now
he just has to give up this pawn he
cannot trade it to an end game
and he's just down upon for absolutely
no reason
and here comes f4 and e5
both coming quickly is it completely
winning
it looks it looks like it's still
well but once you start pushing pause on
the queen side we might start thinking
we might be winning again
but still it looks obvious to play for
e5 robert but it's not easy for white to
break through after this happens
although i like the bishop on f5 that
was nice actually it just shows the
limitation of a bishop right if i put my
king on a dark square
you can't kick my king off it and i
wanted to bring up something important
that the a8
squared matches the light square bishop
because there are times where you
sacrifice your bishop and make a draw
with a rook pawn but not here
because the bishop and the corner match
so e5 he's going to have to go for it
but
then there's no progress to be made at
least that's what dude is thinking
because the king sits on e7 there are no
points of infiltration for the white
king
that's the key that's the key to the
defense you're going to be able to trade
off the bishop somehow
once you play e5 and you see making a
lot of moves instantly
hopefully he's not pre-moving a blunder
in one of these moves
as fabi has just got b7 and beef
d7 and b5 on his mind as his repetition
and no chance to win look at that he
made it
from what i've seen duda seems very
comfortable
in those critical moments the last
seconds it seems like he will have the
edge here
it's not going to be about opening
theory the great bullet meisters like
the icarus of the world
they know it's about playing good enough
moves
quickly and also when the critical
moments happen who blundered
there's no way to predict it clearly
dude has got the edge
from his experience and this but will
probably be able to pull it off
only time will tell certainly will be
the case and while we're talking about
monsters and bullet chests for those of
you subscribed to the chess channel here
enjoy
the second match of the primetime
smackdown and please pray for me because
i'm playing daniel nereditsky who
is a monster at bullet we'll be right
back
[Music]
i'll take i'll take the first defeat
nothing like a comeback i'm not i don't
generally underestimate
my opposition that was uh that was a
fluke yeah i feel like there's nothing
like a good comeback story so i'm happy
just to
come back to be where we are right now
did i hear the word comeback
okay oh knight g5 but i've been here for
years is this a line i have no idea
do you're asking me if something's a
real opening
i this is the one thing where i'm in the
same boat as you i never i'm always
asked
okay i'm gonna be honest my position
looks absolutely horrible i don't think
this is a line
no it looks really bad um
can i get a redo a redo
yeah how about in game i i can i suggest
game three as a redo
oh this feels really bad i'm gonna be
honest i think i'm losing like three
pawns here castle
that b3 pawn is like the kebab i had
yesterday that looks really good
yeah my position looks real horrible all
right let's take this guy can you just
leave me alone
i feel like i'm about 20 seconds i've
played a terrible open you asked me the
thing is when you asked me if it was a
real opening
you asked me if it was a real opening it
just threw me off because i knew it
wasn't real
and it felt like you were being serious
and that just made it more insulting
i see no i was because i you know we
never know these days are these young
players uh playing all sorts of first
you said young player you're talking to
me
so what do you want we need seven man i
think i'm losing now i
i don't really know how to play end
games oh and you won a pawn back oh my
god yeah i did
i did so i'm blundering left and right i
[Laughter]
i was like okay if i'm gonna lose on
time maybe he'll like do some silly
pre-move and i'll get a quick checkmate
i need a group i need a group here
[Music]
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time but this is
the magnus carlson squeeze
um wow and knowing you don't get many
winning positions against
magnus carlson nobody does nicaragua's
playing in front of hundreds of people
imagine being in his shoes right now
wow unbelievable up by four games
well i can resign yeah carl knows it it
started with 16 players
and it all came down to one man magnus
carlson who won
[Music]
this is a pretty great passion i know
people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's
a beast an absolute monster
it has been hecaro's speeches
championship this 2018 in karnakamura
the overall 1c takes it home in the
species championship
honestly these guys have played each
other so much obviously this is a
rematch of last year's scc final what a
finish by the way i mean that's been the
story of the match
kara nakamura has just kind of out
swindled out tricked and out calculated
wesley in the critical moment
up dude that's a nice move wesley's
shaking his head
picara
nakamura holding that position
[Music]
and we return young christophe duda has
a one game lead but we want to remind
everybody to get involved
with guess the move a game is selected
at random and the
top scorers top guessers in that game
will receive cash prizes if you are not
a premium member you will receive
premium memberships here is a recent
game played
and wow 106 guesses that's a ton but
just remind everybody what's happening
next it will be the bullet portion
if the match ends up in a tie we want to
remind
our viewers that there will be four
additional bullet games as a mini match
and if it's still tied after that we get
to armageddon white gets five minutes
black gets three minutes no increment
but black it gets a win
if the game ends as a draw so draw odds
for black so
decided by the chess.com blitz rating
and that should be
jan christoph duda in the case of a tie
and maurice we're going to bring up the
smarter chess predictions one more time
got to get your thoughts here do you
really think that dude is about to take
this bullet
seven to three i don't know i don't know
smarter chess has been right
at least with the first match that is
the five minute portion
we could say not correct on the second
portion gave a five five but it was
really four
four was the score so we could say oh
smarter just didn't get it right that
time but so what smarter chess has been
very right in terms of
the differential and so i'm not going to
go against that right now and i think
that the way duda has handled himself
fabi could be in trouble i
agree with you there duda has been great
under the duress of time trouble fabi
has had some moments of his own
but it seems like duda handles the mouse
speed
and the complications better when the
seconds are dwindling
so with that being said we're about to
have liftoff here in the bullet
and the first couple games i think are
of the incredibly important for fabi he
cannot go down three games
and then hope to go on a streak so hey
we have a petrov
we do have a petrov probably must be
happy to see a petrov on the board his
instinct
o'grady prepared this for the world
championship against magnus
so you will see some of the lines that
he thinks are the most dangerous lines
you can play
and are we frozen or something because
queenie two has
caused black to stop and think for about
10 seconds in a
bullet game i mean are you mad
yeah what's going on here come on dude
you gotta move
i don't get it there must be something
wrong robert you spent all that time
to finally play b6 that's
that's crazy and now probably should
just definitely move instantly
since he saw no danger there knight d4
jeep on is not hanging
as far as fabi's concerned you can have
it bishop takes on g2 yeah
you want it take it again he's giving
away even the h pawn as well robert
saying you want any of those you can
have them because
i'm sacking to get at your king he
certainly is but i like how dude
has responded getting his knight to c5
it's not even about taking this bishop
so much as activating the piece and
bishop b5 trying to get into the c6
square it looks like
but is he in time because bishop c6
bishop takes d4 maurice that'll win a
piece for black
yeah what is he doing well actually he
could take back with the c pawn and he's
true i mean with the deep
the c pawn and b becoming a d-bond and
then hit the knight on c5 so it doesn't
quite win material
doesn't look possible to play bishop to
c6 this is the kind of thing where you
got to be instinctive and just make
moves and here
we see a trade trade bishop takes on c5
the pin at the end white did not
lose a pawn but the game did
fizzle out quite rapidly into what looks
like a bishop
opposite color position and now queen g4
allowing rook to
e4 not queen ca trading i'm a bit
surprised by that
i liked your rookie four move and here
it comes but maurice would even take
note of this
look at the ratings next to their names
duda is 32-23
fabi is 29-24 that is a 300 point gap
however most of that will be in no
increment right they're playing a lot of
pure bullet and winning on the clock
dude is at least i don't think fabi
plays too much bullet chess
right so no problem here for fabi i mean
this game is just drawn
mainly but it's bullet it's equal i
should say but
it's bullet chest anything could happen
although i don't think anything's going
to happen here as the trades continue
another trade and this one looks like it
will be another petrov draw robber
petrov not proving to be anything
in this match and let's talk match
strategy for a second if you're duda
don't you play this out there
just over 27 minutes remaining in the
match keep this going why
agree on a draw it still has some life
left in it and black can never lose
indeed and here this last move by white
was interesting
uh but now it's dead now it's deader
than dead although there is a king
trying to get to g3 but you have to you
have to respect
whites uh white's f pawn if you live if
you give up f6
only 10 seconds left and he's done it
he's gone for it
and push take this one what did he do
he's losing dude he's wearing this he
just blundered
yeah he did bobby has just blundered a
critical pawn
is it completely lost it looks bad but
it may not be totally lost robert
these endings can be no notorious for
being drawn but it looks like he is lost
it looks
bad the only thing he could have going
for him
i would say that this is the wrong pawn
but he can't win this h pawn if that h1
were gone
bishop takes g3 would just be a draw but
you're not winning h pawn so
it's a long wait a minute but he just
gave up a second he should be fine he
just gave him a second pawn
this is lost yeah he resigned that's
just lost
incredible and this is what we're
worried about with fabi that in critical
moments
he'll make mistakes like that one when
he should draw end up losing a game
that's a big point to donate
it certainly was and you know i was kind
of implying it when i was asking you
should do to play on he couldn't lose
the game but foley showed that he could
and now it's a two-game spread and we
are getting d4 once more
yes indeed and that was critical fabi
making a mistake there
and it could really
just go downhill very quickly if fabi's
not careful
it could just it could just get bad so
he needs to stabilize he needs to get
some wins in
he just lost with the white pieces duda
must be feeling fantastic about the
situation right now
he certainly is and the good news for
fabi is that duda his choosing double
edged positions and look at this h5
trying to go h4
and white is trying to get this e pawn
going and open up both the e and the f
files just blast the position open for
your bishops
but fabi has to be happy that the
position is not just dry and he can't
push for more even though duda spent no
time at all maurice
the guy is just in good shape in the
bullet also these guys have been here
before right they've seen positions like
this one
and they know what to do and here we see
h3 by fabi was attending that
queen really what a move keep
getting the g file does he have
a way to blast through king h1 and rook
g1 robert no rook h
rook h8 is coming so you do have to be
mindful of that
i'm looking at queen g5 is there going
to be a sacrifice on the square perhaps
there isn't maybe we're
too focused on g6 but it does look
promising of course
the bishop d2 i'm happy to see if i'm
black for sure
a quiet move and now avoiding the trade
of queens
but man begging the guy to sack on g6
just daring him i wow
that is that looks so scary but the
night guards
the knight i was talking about this
knight on c6 guards the b4 square so
there's no bishop to b4 at any point
but now with the knight there's no
threat no bishop c6 threat but what does
black do when he played rook h5
black is looking much more solid but in
the clock situations about even a4
it seems like aimless moves on the queen
side but he's make sure he's not going
to hang that pawn later in the game and
maurice i'm looking at rook takes e3
at some point for fobby just to trade
off some pieces get in double-edged
position
probably need to score some points and
he's up on the clock the threat is
knight b3 robert knight beat nice and
that bishop
has nowhere to go to maintain so he had
to go for it he played e4
but this looks like it just blunders
material and consistently so
rook f6 and more trades for fobby he is
winning this position there's no
question
about it but can he pull it off with the
time being an issue a knight g5 when
when nice get to g5 you got three oh
it's i think this check i was like no
three wins the queen but he's getting a
knight of three's threatened right now
knight of three is definitely threatened
and he had to back up and it's up to
fabi now knight check and now this
this king is frozen there could be mates
anywhere
but can he get over there and he's
decided just to play queen f4
trade off and go into what looks to be a
superior end game
but i'm not sure he wants to trade off
rooks i mean
straight up minor pieces and just keep
rooks on the board so this last move oh
nice there was a mate threat robber yep
and that's why
uh now dude is trying to push this palm
but the king is in time to get to the
dark squares
oops sorry that was my mistake not now
it isn't
yeah i i made the move by mistake the
king is on block and pump oh watch out
for no there's nothing to watch out for
so
this is weird i keep seeing the eval bar
jump up and down
black obviously was much better but now
the king is cut off on d8
and that palm d6 can't be approached no
this doesn't look
winning anymore just and he's played
this move hoping to
chase the bishop away but this looks
like it should just be drawn
he can get into e6 oh no
and white suddenly picks off the pawn on
g6 and he's going to push his h pawn and
that f5 pawn is dead as well
absolutely atrocious collapse by fabi
with the second sticking down robert and
he can be mad at you because every time
you say it looks like it's going to be a
draw
he loses so those are the words that
fabiano does not want to hear
ever again no more draws the problem is
he's
not cool under the clock ticking
pressure
when it comes down to five or six
seconds left that's when duda is winning
these games
duda is super cool in the critical
moments knows exactly what to do to
manage things
and fabi just seems to be collapsing
every time he certainly is he was
winning that position right he was up a
pawn he was attacking
duda and then somehow he liquidated into
this rook and bishop ending and the
rooks got traded
and he couldn't win and not just that he
lost it's one thing not to win the game
it's another
thing losers yeah so let the guys king
just march into your house
and take all your cookies that was not
cool
that was terrible and now fabi
desperate to just get a draw but i'm not
sure you know we've been talking about
as you said robert
i'm not sure he's going to be getting
any freebies wait that bishop
oh it didn't get trapped wow that was
close it was really close and
the worst part about this position
maurice is it's closed so fabi can play
now he can definitely play this pawn on
b4 is a clear target
and the king can try to come in but
that's why i like judah's move g4
the king can't keep running as he needs
to stay
attached to the f2 pawn not that it has
anywhere to go from d3
but there's a bishop isn't there a
bishop to a5
yes possibility and how do you i mean
you're now
frozen yeah but if the king comes to b2
you bring your knight back to c3 and you
have knight d1 at the end of these
things so
it's weird and i know we've used that
word a lot today but it seems like
white's king can't go and approach the
pawn assuming the knight to kick it
and if that's the case then black is
holding steady
and there goes the king and now no
movement there
how to do anything here
probably take and play you know go for
e5 here it comes
dude is just out playing him incredible
incredible and now
now that he's captured this this is
problematic this is problematic he's
backing up
knight c1 didn't just win the b-pawn
whose b-pawn was worse
after all well now it looks like he's
trying to trade off and get his draw if
he can
we've seen it oh try to trick him with
knight d3 if you take on b4 his knight
d3
painful just trickery everywhere
and he had to move his king and knight
there anyway and he's just squeezing him
with almost no material on the board
he's preventing him from having any
moves
here comes king e4 why not just bring
that king in knight c1 check
and then you take on b3 and this king is
just walking in or winning the e3 pawn
oh this is it no check check king if two
and then when you take you can take on
b4
uh i was trying to go king d3 at the end
there but you might be right maybe it's
like barely
just holding on and here you know
another variation here
asking white white's about to get in
zugsvang however a little bit of
challenge for him as the bishop is
headed to g5 with the d4 threat
and this is problematic and it's there
not only is it problematic it's on the
board it's over
duda is owning the position bishop takes
isn't d3 winning material yep
he takes here first but d3 still
promising but maybe there's even his
bishop retreat and then d3 with tempo he
takes
well he sees the yummies on the other
side of the board you can't stop those
phones from dropping
completely devastating fabiano right now
in the bullet
all predictions looking very good
and a 12 to 8 score three wins in a row
the way fabi started this
this match he won three in a row it is
duda's turn to show his superiority in
the bullet
as he's won three in a row will it only
be 7-3 robert because
right now it's just a one-way train
running all over bobby's tracks yeah i
don't think that
dude is going to look back from here and
he is winning all these games he's a
great position in this one as well
and fabi's in that mindset now i don't
care if i lose because i have to win
right
you a draw is getting close to the same
as a loss because they're only
just under 18 minutes left as the match
clock ticks down
and all right so taking on c4 is
possible here
do it don't think i mean just go for it
you have to right you have to just go
and he's just worried about age 4-h
he's not this is not the time to
hesitate or think
you've got to make moves and this he did
he did pause
and now by playing b4 by pausing so long
to play b4
he has now shut down his own attack and
he has to restart the whole thing and
this is not good
it is a king's indian style with f5 and
maybe f4 coming but
yeah your kings on g8 the opponent's
kings on the queen side so whose attack
is going to be better
i don't really see an attack against
this white king because of the pawn on
b4 not
allowing about to open up that side of
the board but i don't see white's attack
either
mixed bag here right but that's we
wanted to get some attack from
for black that's what the whole position
was supposed to be about and
white will look to make those pawn
breaks g4 eventually
will come on that side of the board
black sometimes wants to play the move
e4 when the timing is right if
you could combine it with an opening on
the other side of the board as well
robert
wouldn't it be sweet if you had already
taken the pawn on c4
wouldn't that be nice to just have an
open file directed at white's king
it certainly would and unfortunately for
fabi that's no longer a possibility
he loses bishop but the knight is a
reasonable defender but you're right
maurice i'm looking at g4 ideas
how does black attack here knight coming
to c5 does make sense
and then perhaps there is an e4 you saw
this a mile away
well i was trying to open up a line for
the bill we took them
on that is some real i'm
honest right there boy oh my goodness he
took the pawn
on before and said i don't believe you
have a strong enough attack
i'm going for it i would never have even
thought twice once maybe but twice we're
taking this pawn
on that square now look at the
punishment as black's pieces
are just making this incursion on the
dark squares
incredible oh my god look at black's
pieces my goodness
it gets better and better but wait wait
wait you give the
so the queen's up for a couple of rooks
rookie seven coming
this king of g8 isn't so safe either
what's happening
i'm not sure but this now queen b4 and
the queen showing
its skill as a versatile attacker and
this is
definitely winning now for white uh for
black excuse me
no question about it but will he make
sure he doesn't blunder somehow
in this position and he doesn't have
much time and we know what happens we're
probably wasting time trouble he's gonna
scoop
off all these pawns now the bishop one
g7 on attack and go here quickie to
check
okay takes this one said wait
he's just taking all of them dangerous
position though he has not figured out
he's let the king go all the way down
the board
and he missed the mate and look at this
the valuation nest is about level here
which means that white's probably going
to win
white is definitely for choice now
unbelievable what has happened here
what a turnaround bobby blew that game
if you don't win this game you win none
you if you can't win a game like this
one you you're not winning any of the
games
unbelievable that he lost that game oh
yeah we're gonna bring the analysis
board because he missed checkmate in two
moves
and that's something that you can't miss
right when he
started moving his queen away here
at this point queen b3 check king takes
c5
queens e3 is made and i know it's not
the first thing that may come to your
mind but you have to find the checkmate
you have to find the checkmate the first
check is easy the next one you look for
that's you have to find the checkmate by
the way even in even in that position
queen b6 check picks off the knight
picks up the bishop
on f6 so you have to keep relentlessly
attacking on every move that's what you
do
in a position like this you don't start
going over the other side and messing
around
no this this was critical this was
critical and now he's down five
and this match is done yeah
down five with just under 14 minutes he
technically has a chance but if he
couldn't win that game
it's very unlikely he's gonna start
winning five in a row but
duda has done that himself against
alexander grishok
and against sergey karjakin in speeches
championships past
but duda is the one with the lead so i
not sure where
believers in fabi's chances yeah nobody
believes in it right now and look at
this knight on f4 all of a sudden
he's down upon is black but you just get
this feeling like black is on the
the prowl on the attack coming
initiative
momentum everything on
this polish wonderkids side well i guess
he's not so young
anymore but still he is
showing his incredible ability at this
time control and look at that queen
sitting on h4
wondering what it's doing over there
robert is one square is going to g3 at
least it's safe for now the bishop on b3
covers the weak pawns and is a nice
attacking piece
so i could see this turning in fabi's
favor if he's able just to
make his pieces a little bit more
harmonious but yeah this has been
all duda it's been a great display of
bullet skill by him
and wesley so awaits the winner of this
matchup
i'm not sure wesley's happy to have to
face duda who
obviously is just on inform
great form i hear you i hear you but i
would say at the same time
that as this position seems to be
getting problematic for duda as
white's queen has gotten out of danger
and
now he just needs to play something to
deal with the potential
uh pawn com coming down the board he's
up a pawn he's got the open lines
this looks good for white this this is
the kind of game you say
this has got to be bobby's game he's got
27 seconds with
a second increment coming at him each
time he should not blow this one
and now the question is how to finish it
off rook d6 looks like a natural move
robert
and then get the ball going down the
field but
what is he doing he's giving black
chances right h3 check
is going to come i understand i don't
understand
now now he's being hyper defensive
and that knight on f4 looks marvelous
i think now i'm also worried about
getting mated
there's something weird i mean i i'm
gonna get three
okay i'm just worried now for fabi he's
played this in such tepid fashion
i'm scared yeah this um he's giving up
his entire advantage me g3 now opening
up the uh
he might get mated you're right i'm i'm
saying i'm saying he's on the edge of
being mated he's got to be careful
wow a6 discovered none of them are good
i guess
e3 also e3 looks crushing you can get
out of this
96 check wait didn't that pick up the
rook it sure did look like
the phone was promoting the part without
wow tactics
but now what about now is it oh
what's going on he can take that and he
can take that
and in time pressure fabia has pulled it
off
no yo seriously
these games are definitely not good for
the heart medications i mean maybe good
for the may be good for the heart
medications in fact
because that was insane that was insane
are you trying to say they're supporting
big pharma over here because
yeah i'm in some pain watching these
games for sure but there were some good
tactics bobby staying
in this match with that victory and look
at him right now he's
above a minute on the clock so he's in
his element
in terms of the opening preparation and
his position looks just fine
he it's just not right about uh can't
even speak it's not about
right now it's about how he progresses
from here because we've seen him get
plenty of good positions some winning
positions
and then in the scramble that's when
things go awry
sometimes you play yourself into form
but then sometimes it's too late
yeah and we might be seeing this for
fabi that slowly he's getting there
getting there getting there but it may
end up being too late when we're done
and this move 94 uh black
returns the favor by putting the knight
on c4 both of them with these
tricky bishops black's bishop is worse
than white's c1 bishop
so that's going to be a problem but
black can at least brag
about the pawn on a3 being a target
that pawn on a3 will be a long-term
target so i can say
i've got that guy under control what do
you have and look at this trade on d7
for the bishop and now a trade on f6
white has a dream of putting a queen on
86 at some point so black has to be very
alert
to this possibility probably putting his
own queen
to that score wait a second now wait a
second isn't there a bishop 86 bishop
g7 idea robert you know
yeah straight out of brooklyn you know
that weird why
g4 and e5 were the next two moves i know
what's
happening this is what they tell you
right the best way to defend your king
is breaking open the center if you're
getting attacking the flight you can't
do anything
let's go but you're right what the
and here we go as now
this is a brawl with the knight on a6
that's the one thing i'm not feeling
for black right now as white is intent
on blowing him up
knight g4 knight e5 hitting the g4 rook
allows rook takes on d4
so not a sensible move but h5 and look
at the attack
okay knight 95 is asking again to be
played
and look at four he dropped the tactic
f7 check is coming queen did not belong
over there
while duda finds these nice ideas robert
when the pressure's on and fabi misses
little tricks like that
in time pressure dude is just an
absolute boss he loses one game
you think well is he going to be able to
keep his composure and keep playing the
great level ability has been the answer
is clearly yes and
now there are under eight minutes it's a
five game lead this match
effectively is over five games we'll do
it
no question about it the question will
now be the margin
plus five at the moment smarter chess
said it was gonna be a four game margin
is plus five at the moment so close
indeed and all he needs is a few draws
those duda
for this to be completely over over
not good for fobby fans at all and this
game
no exception to that black is up a pawn
white has you know quality rook on d1
bishop one b6 great
but you're down upon as we're entering
towards a
pure ending and i mean dude is just a
monster a lot of money at stake
of course that dude is gonna take the
lion's share the two thousand dollars
for being the winner plus the win
percentage
uh it's all going his way he should be a
very happy what's he 21
22 he's a youngster getting a good
payday
indeed and look at this
evil two connected passers
white desperate right here you you know
when you're losing badly robert we've
all been there
and whatever you do it feels like fluff
your opponent just swatting your moves
like flies like get out of here
that's nothing i'ma stop that i'm gonna
take this i'm gonna own you and now he's
taking yet another pawn
probably made it a vein attempt with g4
and it just as strong as fabi is
you feel weak you feel helpless as your
opponent just finds
every move look at this trick knight d7
instantly you couldn't take on b7
i mean he's showing off right now rook
d7 looking for more traffic
take his g5 i mean the guy is just come
on man on every move he's finding this
ridiculous skill and just winning with
style and ease and composure
and flow up six right now
you know maurice we started off this
match fabi was up three nothing
right we're like dang like this is going
potentially a lopsided affair in fobby's
favor and then something started
clicking for duda
and it's just a totally different match
from the start of the five minute
you know what is four to one fabi ever
since it's been
all young kristoff and he looks like
he's smiling right now
laughing enjoying this bobby's leaning
back probably he's no longer interested
he's no longer interested he knows the
match is over he's down six
he got punished pummeled into submission
and he's leaning back he's he can't
bring himself
to come up to the screen and really
focus he's just making moves now because
he just wants it to be over
and well fortunately for him there's
only five minutes remaining but yeah it
must be
frustrating for fabi because year after
year he takes part in the speeches
championship
and well it's you know hard for him he
lost to
levon oroni and i think it was like 20
to 5 or 21 to 5 something
ridiculous for a player of fabiano's
caliber
but something about these blitz and
eventually the bullet portion
they don't go his way he needs to
continue working on that
you know it's interesting because i
think fabi's probably relieved
to be gone like just you know okay
okay he did not want to lose let's be
let's be fair but
bobby's trying to become the world chess
champion there's no other ambition he
has
he's trying to become the world chess
champion the way he's going to do that
he's going to be to win candidate
match again matches or candice
tournament again
and face the best player in the world
and beat him
and this one minute is not his thing
he's not going to sit around and become
a maestro at bullet chest he's just not
he's not going to spend
hours and hours and days and days and
weeks and weeks so that one day he can
say
hey guys i'm good at bullet now
that's just not him he's not going to do
that he'll leave the bullet
specialist he'll leave bullet chest to
the bullet specialist he'll try to do
well
when the time comes but he's not going
to spend all his time
trying to do this and he'll compete in
these events he you know now he's really
in
a lot of trouble again in this position
but you know frankly he's just
this is not what he's about yeah no i
think you summed it up very well that
his focus is very clear
he wants to do well when he's invited
and plays in these events but he's not
going to
prioritize these speeches events over
the world championship that he wants to
play in once more
so i'm completely with you maurice's
position again not looking very good
but the match already is pretty much
done rook g3 looks possible but there's
quincy one check
to be careful about but rook g3 was
trying to distract the rook it said he
goes for the d-pawn
trying to kick this knight away made
bishop d7 and winning the d4 pawn but
you're right i'm with you maurice um
fabi has a focus and that's the
candidates tournament which
who knows when that will even take place
at this point
yeah in the meantime people are getting
good money for playing in these kind of
events
and unfortunately uh for for fabi
he's not going to get the top dollar
unless he starts winning some of these
online events and he's watching other
players
who are getting it done ahead of him as
he
just he's not able to keep up as well he
did have a great showing in clutch chess
fantastic showing fantastic match
against magnus want some money there
but if he's going to win the top top
dollar
got to be able to win some of these
online events and it's just not yet not
his priority
yeah and magnus himself he had that
interview that jonathan tisdale
uh published on chess life online i saw
and magnus said that okay
you know bobby steals a chance at the
candidates he's down one point at the
halfway mark
oh we got mated in that one yeah i
honestly i've
you know he's stopped kind of looking at
how bad it's been for him
but magnus said that his toughest
challenge by far
is fabiano caruana so that speaks
volumes
most people in the know in the chess
world see the ratings
probably number two for a long time and
it's pretty distant between him
and magnus but also between him and
number three so that's the toughest
competitor
for magnus in classical chess which is
the highest
quality of of games so you're right
probably just
you know he's not going to focus on the
speeches but he has been better in rapid
but that will not translate into bullet
success
agreed agreed i think this is his worst
time control without any
doubt about it rapid chess and as i
mentioned clutch chessy did well
because rapid chess he's been better
without any question but when you start
going
not just for blitz but you start going
to bullet that's just not his thing
and he's not he's not interested
interested in training for this excuse
me
and he's not interested in in overall
even if he did well
okay i did well no of course he wants to
do well but
it's not the proof the proof in the
pudding for him is classical chess and
becoming world champ
yeah indeed and all credit to young
christoph duda who has been
an absolute monster today he started off
on the
absolute terrible footage like he wasn't
even awake yet but then
something inside of him really woke up
and he started roaring
and fabiano has been on the back foot
ever since so
dude on this final game here unless it
ends quickly we have 35 seconds counting
down this should be
the last game and he's going to win this
match and it's going to look
very one-sided but it's all been decided
in the bullet we see here it's seven to
one
currently in bullet in dude's favor he
entered up
one point now it's a seven point lead by
the way
if we just do a little math the match as
you mentioned three zero to start yes
yes since then it's been 16
to six is the score 16-6
that is a comeback and more than a
comeback a straight beat down once
he got his rhythm 16-6 to turn things
around
what a roll what a run and he just
just plumbing fobby into submission and
especially in the bullet that was the
difference maker
the bullet was indeed the difference
make because there were only a points up
there was only a point separating them
after the five minute portion and the
three minute push
that's huge credit to uh duda because he
knew he was the favorite in bullet
and the fact that he was able to come
back from that early deficit and just
keep the match not just close but
in a lead for him right that speaks
volumes about his talent in this final
game here i mean look at this king on e4
it's like a checkmate that it feels like
okay it won't get mated but
this is uh not not
going well for fabi and he's just trying
it doesn't matter it'd be nice to win
the last game though you know i mean one
of those things
it's nice to win the nice game but
sharks like duda they try to win
everything
and they don't want to give him anything
whatsoever as dude is trying to blitz
through
these next moves and maybe one day hit
this king but it looks
as though it's all about the time down
look at that oh but he had a trick back
because the work on c2 was under attack
but
there should be some winning discoveries
okay where's the main thing that
is looking bad the maid is coming where
is it though
look at the 396. gang up on the on the
king and finally
a mate to finish it off and dude is
smiling there
happy as he's won the match 17-9 a 17-6
run after going down 3-0
kudos he definitely dominated the match
and we can say smarter chess kind of had
it right
but not as bad as the final result
actually was i think it was 8-1
in the blitz in the bullet it was indeed
so
smart exactly where the predictions were
trending and it was worse than uh
even predicted yeah so you have to give
our a nod to smartchest
accurate once again foiled my thoughts
and
i just i'll never get over it but you
know really
just big props to jkd
who scores a monster victory sends a
message to the rest of the field
and he'll have wesley so up next wesley
did defeat him soundly
in a prior speech championship but right
now it's a new
young christopher duda some renewed
confidence but we'll hear it from the
players
in a few so please enjoy the final prime
time smackdown video you know it's the
last one
clearly dania did some work against me
sorry for everyone who roots for me i
don't know why you do that but
we're gonna take our final break we'll
bring the players in for the call and
we'll interview them
to conclude the speed chess championship
opening round match
i came into this match thinking i was
going to lose and
you know it is all going according to
that plan but that's not the plan we
want to see it happen today
it is precisely the plan that we want to
see all right all right all right
gonna take a breath gonna take a breath
me too uh preparing for you seem
so chill right now i always am
can you put a photo of me on your wall
please like i see photos of other people
there
and right i feel like that's my family
robert yeah we spent enough time
together so
yeah oh you're saying you're family oh
yeah you know well maybe
maybe after 10 games you'll be familiar
that's sadly probably the case so let's
just let's just leave me alone for a
second daniel oh
[Music]
this doesn't feel very good for me no it
doesn't i'm going gonna play this
positionally just get the knight back
dude why are you such a bully today i'm
i'm feeling good
i've done nothing but be a friend to you
that feels factual we might have to
reconsider our
a record then wait i think my position
is not quite as oh
look yeah do it come on come on man just
leave me
let's see it actually no i don't like it
okay you think i missed that yeah i do
no i didn't i saw that all the way
all right uh now what do i do all right
take credit back
no this is exactly these are the
positions i live for robert sadly that's
true and i don't have much time
so let's just run my keyboard let's take
this oh shoot
i forgot that funny thing is okay takes
and let's find the most clinical
thing you're such a
rookie one okay at least you didn't lose
your queen you have that as solace
you know you are just getting a big head
and i don't like it
i'm getting a massive head i always have
i've always had one
i'd like to be dying that was just a
nice kid
oh no i thought i had you for a second
my technique here is atrocious as usual
but i was so excited i hope you
understand that
oh crap that is i didn't recognize the
the gravity of that threat for a second
there
can you just leave me alone and not
checkmate me nope
don you okay you're too good man you're
too good but you know what
you needed something positive in your
life so that's why i agree to play you
okay robert hessel already is a positive
you have to understand
i play very little bullet right and so
i'm just here to make sure that you are
a happy person
i see i see that explains that really
explains everything robert i mean i
before this i i didn't know what your
intentions and motivations were but now
i do
but on a serious note can my photo go up
on your wall that would make me
feel pretty absolutely i'd be i'd be
honored
you'd be honored to have my phone on
your wall yes is he this is the type of
traffic that's just what i say to people
yeah just to make him feel good exactly
you were just
bullying me after you just destroyed me
on the chest
well it's like that um most interesting
man in the world in those dosakis
commercials he once had an awkward
moment just to see how it feels
and we are joined by the players after
what was a very exhilarating match
young christophe duda congratulations
and i have to ask
after you were down three nothing how
were you able to right the ship
and turn the match around and score a
decisive victory
yeah i knew that the beginning of the
match might be very difficult for me
i didn't expect to zero out the three of
course but
uh yeah usually i start with closing i
think
it's my matches so yeah but i mean it's
uh
okay i played quite badly in in that
game obviously but
yeah afterwards i i was like kind of you
know
okay getting into the match because
yeah at the beginning again often like
not playing very well yeah
bobby this match was yours at the
beginning it looked very powerful for
you
you must have been disappointed when it
started turning around can you
can you pinpoint anywhere in the match
that you felt like
you let this slip away
um well i had a feeling that the bullet
would be
would be really tough for me i didn't
expect it to go as badly as it did but i
had a feeling that i would be
a pretty serious underdog and bullet so
i was hoping to
to make a mark in uh in the first two
segments
and and yeah i was starting out well but
um
uh yeah i guess that you know christoph
was still not fully adjusted
at the start and then he started to
forget his form
and uh i probably just shouldn't have
been playing the french so much it
worked out at the start but then i was
getting these
strategies strategically awful positions
and
uh and basically it was just it was a
complete disaster around that point
um i also lost this really really
unnecessary game
that uh when young kristoff played
took on f4 and i lost him like 10 moves
with white and that was
so yeah that was that was a big
disappointment around that moment um
then later it seemed like it kind of
equalized in in the three-minute portion
it was pretty
pretty balanced um but yeah it was
i i didn't really have a chance uh at
the end yeah and fabio i was gonna make
a joke if you were playing the french
just to get under my skin
knowing my feelings about the opening
but um you know you knew the bullet
probably was going to
quite heavily favor young kristoff were
you working on bullet
behind the scenes or was that something
that you just said i'm not going to be
able to get better in time for this
match to be able to
you know equalize the the score with him
in the time control
no i i i wasn't playing any bullet i
also wasn't playing any blitz before i
didn't really
um i don't know i i you know i've sort
of been on vacation here and i haven't
really wanted to
play online chess too much before this
match uh
and okay it seems like uh
i mean i i don't think that i'm going to
improve massively by playing a few
bullet games before the match you know
um it's it's sort of like
i'm just panicking when i'm down to
seconds and this is not a thing that you
can
you can really correct in a day or two
congratulations you play
bullets so well what is the key
to your style to this ability do you
live
when you were growing up playing bullet
all the time i did i
played blood well i mean i thought i was
like extremely
lucky to die in the bullet because i was
okay winning games either equal or worse
for me maybe even lost
sometimes so yeah i wasn't actually i
mean i'm not very
pleased with uh the way i play bullet
obviously the score is too high
like yeah i said i was like extremely
lucky
all the time and um yeah i've been i've
been playing
a lot actually before this match a lot
of bullets so
yeah i guess i i was just not like
on the internet well young kristoff do
you think that
playing in the invitational helped you
because you got to play
very strong opponents like karjakin
jeffrey jean grishoek
and minleigh so do you think that helped
you in preparation for this match
yeah obviously i mean you know it's
never enough
i'm glad and well i think that you know
to be in good shape one can like have to
play all the time
because otherwise you were just too slow
and
yeah but as i said i mean that was
extremely lucky today and
definitely was too high
i think you're knocking yourself we saw
some brilliant games being played and
brilliant instincts
at the end of that one as well fabi i
made this point that bullet
may not be your thing and it's not going
to be your thing
you have big aspirations become becoming
the best player in the world becoming
world champion
is that fair to say that you you want to
play and want to do well but you're
you're probably not going to train a lot
for bullet chess specifically
as you have higher aspirations i i enjoy
blitz and rapid and
uh and i you know i want to do well um i
mean
of course i want to do well in all
events i play in um but bullet is not
something that i've ever had much
much interest in um it's it's not really
my thing
um but yeah in blitz and rapid uh
i mean i i do enjoy playing quite a lot
and and i do want to have good results
um uh yeah i i don't think that i'm
going to be
a basketball player at any time
totally fair and well young kristoff
will end the
interview with you you play wesley so
next
and in the previous match against wesley
so he
was able to beat you and seem to
have a good uh performance against you
do you think that things have changed in
the last couple years
do you feel ready for the challenge of
facing wesley next
well obviously whether it is a very
difficult opponent for everyone
especially when
yeah usually you know um i either win
i mean nature game against wesley or i
are just suffering
every game so it's like if i don't win
25 moves then it's
you know going to be the
good guy yeah i mean obviously he's very
strong and he
i think he was i mean reaching final all
the time
yeah in every year so yeah but i mean
okay
everyone is difficult in this tournament
so yeah and i'm happy to have a chance
to
the revenge for sure
well thank you both for joining us after
the match
i know it was a long affair um young
christoph congratulations once again and
fabi's sorry didn't go your way but it's
always a pleasure to
watch your games thank you guys thanks
and not only is john chris up due to the
winner of today's match we have several
winners of
some cash prizes they guessed the move
correctly we have
feeding master yavru court 40 that's a
repeat customer maurice
winning the 75 cash i believe twice in a
row now
that's nice man you sit and hang out and
watch some chats get some moves
and get 75 bucks in your pocket hey
that's that sounds good can you imagine
if you could watch other sports and do
that
well i mean even better is winning a
diamond membership and look at that
username beer chugger
multitasking at its finest right indeed
well congrats to everybody who hung in
there guessed those moves
and took home a little cash and some
membership as well
for sure and you'll have an opportunity
to continue guessing the move tomorrow
because
vladislav artemyev takes on anish giri
in our last
first round matchup to decide the final
quarter finalist and we'll bring
our smarter chess predictions up that
match takes place tomorrow 9 a.m pacific
look at this we have artemia the 61
favorite 15 and a half 13 and a half
predicted final score
and that is decided no surprises here in
the bullet segment what do you think
about that maurice
well it seems fair seems fair aneesh
geary is not known for his
blitz prowess or hyper blitz hyper
bullet prowess
obviously one of the best players in the
world no question about it but our
temiev
and these these young guns super young
guns and this is not
one of the the older guys i mean it's
not like he's getting the cane out yet
but these these young young guns they
just seem like they
grow up on bullets and bullets and blitz
and
anything that's quick the minds work a
whole different way so i think the
slight edge toward tamiya makes sense
but don't count a niche out of this
match and i love our tenuous photo by
the way everybody else is happy
and smiling he's just looking like
through you
and he's ready to grab your soul through
your chest
and then add it to his collection he's
he's the guy you hire
uh to to do to play the assassin in the
in the
jason bourne movies you know like like
this guy's gonna walk over and say okay
you know
you know what time it is right you say
okay so it's over now
and he plays like it too he certainly
does maurice and
i've had a great day here with you it
was a fun match of course the final
score
went in one direction all the way for
young chris of duda but it was
neck and neck before the bullet portion
so maurice any kind of final thoughts on
what was another
excellent speeches championship match
indeed the first
part of the match maybe even the i would
say the first
two-thirds of the match was so
competitive was so interesting
and it started out with probably needing
the first three wins that it turns out
to just keep it competitive
but in the end the part of the the
competition where we as commentators
we really want to be on the edges of our
seats and biting our fingernails what's
going to happen who's going to win
it's so close maybe there'll be a tie
break we didn't get to see that because
of the spectacular play by duda
at the end to show that hey bullet is
his thing
oh we'll see the matches are going to
get more and more interesting
as the winners start to move up in these
brackets
and it's gonna be amazing if it's
anything like the beginning of this
match was
like future matches i think will be
we're in for a treat in the rest of the
speeches championship
we certainly are and we heard it from
jan christoph due to himself he'll move
on to
wesley so who's such a solid and
spectacular player that he's like
well it's an honor to play anybody i'm
thrilled to move on we'll see how it
goes
and with that i just want to thank
everybody behind the scenes doing all
this work our production
team our graphic designers and our
moderators of course everybody who's
tuned in throughout the show
who's watching and supporting and
maurice i want to thank you you always
make it so fun because you're energy
it's so authentic i know how much you
love chess i'm the same way
and you know we go back but it's fun
every single time it's a new experience
so thank you so much barney
always fun always fun looking forward to
the next time
absolutely see everybody enjoy the rest
of your sunday
i'm not sure anybody's winning here rook
cietas
the king is on age six what
come on now this is not real no way
you're surviving this position
queen c7 a trade i think they're just
blitzing now they're not sure what's
happening
at all what's this oh my gosh here comes
the king
this is g4 is a bad move g4 was
definitely a bad move it did
not it was not correct but you know what
right around now it doesn't matter what
correct is
you